This is Jocko podcast number 57 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Okay.
If the outcome of the battle is favorable,
one should not be satisfied with merely driving the enemy back.
This is a mistake made by inexperienced leaders who do not know how to take
advantage of an opportunity and who like to hear the saying be victorious,
but do not press your victory too hard
by not seizing the opportunity.
These people only cause themselves in more trouble and place the ultimate
results in doubt.
There can be no rest until the enemy is completely destroyed.
If they seek refuge behind fortifications,
apply pressure by direct force or by preventing them from getting more supplies
for men and horses until they are annihilated or else agree to a treaty to our
advantage,
one should not slacking after driving them back just a short distance nor after
so much hard work and the dangers of war should one jeopardize the success of
the whole campaign
because of lack of persistence.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Now that's some direction there on how to pursue your enemy until they are
completely destroyed
and that direction comes from a book called
strategic on a book that's normally a credited to a guy by the name of Flavius
Mauritius Tiberias Augustus or as he is more commonly called Maurice Emperor
and he was the emperor of eastern room,
which is what we now call Byzantine,
a term that wasn't even created until the 16th century,
but Maurice wasn't Roman emperor who started his journey as a soldier,
a general who campaigns successfully against the Persians,
the avatars,
the lombards all over Persia and the Balkans and basically around the
Mediterranean Sea and his military experience served them well and this is the
book that he's credited with Andy Unit.
He details a variety of the mindset of the famous Roman Legion and what ahead
evolve too,
especially as they adopted the strengths of their enemies.
Yeah,
and transitioned to use horses along with the use of Lance's and spears and bow
and Arrow in swords.
Again,
all these things that you'd be using them all together
much as we do today,
what we call combined arms,
which is when we attack from the sea and from the air,
we land forces and we dropped bombs and we use artillery.
We use everything to lock people,
get people in the combined arms dilemma,
my favorite ideas
and something that's that combined arms dilemma.
It's when you're getting attacked with all these from all these different
positions,
it's very hard to contend with.
And obviously the,
they were able to do this as they adapt the different their enemies,
they adapted what they use,
but then they use them together.
And so this book,
Maurice's book,
Strategic Con,
captures a lot of those ideas.
I know it's no surprise,
but a lot of these ideas remain pertinent today.
And I know it's no surprise,
but not only on the battlefield,
but also in business and in life
and famous historian Charles Oh mom said about the Byzantine armies in courage.
They were equal to their enemies in discipline,
organization and armament,
far superior.
Okay.
And we go into the,
go into the introduction in this book a little bit here because there's some
good information to know about.
And here we go.
From the,
from the introduction to the book,
they inherited the long tradition of Roman tactics and strategy with its
emphasis on constant adaptation to the changing of war.
It was largely this remarkable ability to adapt to new situations and new
peoples,
which guaranteed the Byzantine military success gotta be adaptable.
The Byzantines moreover,
like the Romans took warfare very seriously for the Byzantines war was an art to
be practiced by professionals.
They possessed books on all aspects of warfare,
which were collected,
copied over and over again
and red.
The fact that officers in the Byzantine army had to be able to read and write by
itself sets it apart from other medieval armies.
So obviously we do a lot of reading over here in this tradition,
right?
This is what set them apart.
One of the things that set them apart was the fact that they read and they
collected books on this subject.
Byzantine General's carefully studied the habits and tactics of their enemies.
Whereas Western nights found themselves at a loss when facing an unknown foes.
The western European considered himself a good warrior.
If he could ride and wheeled his weapons well,
and if he showed no fear.
Okay,
so that's cool.
You can ride and you can,
you can wield your web as well and you show no fear.
For the Byzantine,
it was not superior strength or courage which won battles.
But after God's favor,
thorough planning and intelligence,
nothing could be left to chance.
Marise twice reminds his readers that the Byzantine general should never have to
admit.
I did not expect that.
Now let's get,
so that's,
that's just from the introduction kind of getting into the book and now we'll go
to the actual book and I'm not going to go into the whole thing of who actually
put these words on the paper.
Again,
it's credited to Maurice,
but did someone else possibly write it and he blessed it?
Did he tell someone right it,
did he have a ghost writer?
I don't know,
but he's the guy that's credited as having the brains behind it.
Starting off here.
The training and drilling of the individual soldier,
he should be trained to shoot rapidly on foot either in the Roman or the Persian
manner.
Speed is important in shaking the Arrow loosened,
discharging it with force.
This is essential and should be practiced while mounted.
In fact,
even when the Arrow is well aimed firing slowly as useless,
he should practice shooting rapidly on foot from a certain distance at a spear
or some other target person that you're shooting at a spear with a bow and
Arrow.
He should shoot also rapidly mounted on his horse at a run to the front,
the rear right and left.
He should practice leaping onto the horse on horseback at a run.
He should fire one or two wars rap arrows rapidly and put the string,
the strong bow in its case.
If it is wide enough or in the half case designed for this purpose and then you
should grab the spear which he has been carrying on his back with the strong bow
in its case,
he should hold the spear in his hand and quickly replaced on his back and
grabbed the bow.
Is a good idea for soldiers to practice all of this while mounted on the march
in their own country for such exercises,
do not interfere with marching and do not wear out the horses.
The reason I had to put this in here,
this cause this is very much what we do in the seal teams.
And you're shooting,
you're shooting off hand,
which means you're shooting with your weekend.
We reloading magazines with only one hand.
So you've got to put the,
put the weapon between your legs,
you gotta pull them bags,
you're doing all this stuff,
you're shooting while you're running,
you're shooting while you're laying down,
you're shooting while you're behind a vehicle,
you're shooting from inside a vehicle,
you're shooting from outside of vehicle.
You're,
you're doing all these things,
all these different ways all the time.
Because the better you get in all these strange situations,
the better you're gonna perform.
Any strange situations,
and you can apply this to any,
you know,
a busy enough talked about this before.
When you're dealing with business,
you want to train your people so they can handle these weird situations.
You know,
be a bad customer.
You don't pretend to be the be a bad.
And if you've got leaders that you're trading,
be a pourable employee,
be that person,
put them to the test.
How are they going to handle employee that flies off the handle?
How are they going to handle employee that doesn't fly off the handle at all?
Verbal but just goes cold of what are you going to do now?
How are you going to handle this person?
Yeah.
I remember you guys were doing at the muster,
you guys are doing that.
You did that role playing thing real quick.
It was like real quick too.
And Yeah,
when I caught Lafe off guard.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're going to role play.
All right,
let's do this.
Oh Yeah,
when you've presented the little,
yeah.
But man,
that was such a good point though,
because you go through one situation,
right?
And the guy liked is like,
I don't got time for you or whatever is however years went and then you're like,
okay.
And you get to,
you get to put yourself through a potential situation.
And then at the end of it you said,
okay,
look,
we just went through that and we did it.
And you know,
maybe there was problems,
maybe not,
but now you're familiar with it.
Kind of like the lights are on now.
You're not going live into a dark room,
not knowing,
you know,
you're doing exactly what Marie said to do here,
which is the most important thing is intelligence.
So it's combining what he's saying,
right.
The more you prepare for that in that particular situation,
that live life.
And I did that little roleplay on.
Yeah.
He acted like he was a company commander that didn't have time for me.
And he took it to the next level and said,
I don't have time for you because I got guys in combat.
Right.
And I've gotten troops in contact,
which is,
you know,
when you've got troops in contact,
that's where everyone's going to focus on that.
So I'm in there playing this young seal officer going,
excuse me,
captain.
Hey,
I'd like to talk to you about an operation.
We're going to do in your area of operations tonight.
Leif says,
Hey,
I'm busy.
I got troops in contact.
Leave me alone.
Yeah.
And I was kind of taken aback and I said,
sir,
you know what?
Can you just tell me where your ops officers?
And I'll go talk to him.
And that was it.
I overcame it because what else are you going to do?
But it took me a second.
I had to think on my feet.
If that ever happened again,
I would have to think on my feet and I have the answer.
And you went through like if you were to do that in a real situation and you
stumble you to know what to do,
that web,
huge deal.
It's looking bad.
You know,
you're not giving any confidence.
You're,
you're saying,
hey,
I want to come into your area of operations and execute a mission tonight and I
can't even put a sentence together.
Yeah,
not good.
Yeah.
So that's why we rehearse.
That's why rehearse worst case scenarios.
That's why you'd practice shooting on the horse off the horse,
putting your bow way,
pulling it back out,
thrown your spear,
get,
that's what you do.
Yeah.
It's crazy how even going through once Islamic time,
well,
when I work with companies,
I'll do a role play and I'll tell them,
watch what happens in three times,
three iterations.
They get that much better.
They'll go from totally stumbling and not being able to handle a bad employee to
where the third time they got it.
That's all it takes.
Then it was the same thing we put through in the,
in the seal teams with guys through really hard training scenarios and they
would blow it and I'd kill all this training.
I'd kill all the good guys.
Right?
They'd all be getting hit with paint ball.
You're dead.
Next time I'd say,
okay,
here's the mistake.
You May,
let's look at it.
What would you do?
Step back?
What would you do different?
Nah,
man,
I didn't see that.
I got,
you know,
I got drawn to the situation I should.
Okay,
so let's do it again.
They're going to be 50% better than the next time the neck,
the time after that,
we can't even catch them anymore because they got it.
Nope.
That's crazy preparation.
All right.
Going back to the book,
another thing that Maria says,
in actual combat,
nobody can properly supervise the entire battle since the line is spread out so
far and some can dessert from their bands and bands is,
there's two meanings of the word abandons.
One is a flag,
like this is our flag,
but then it's also a group of about 300 troops.
So what he's saying is that people can can dessert back to the book unnoticed
and give all others and excuse to retreat.
If they do retreat,
there's no way of turning back or of checking the flight for.
Nobody is able to get them back since,
as we said,
the whole army is routed.
So he said this is,
this is why we need a little bit of decentralized command.
Right?
Cause he's saying you're no one can.
No one's going to know you can't keep track.
The whole battle.
How many people can you keep track of during battle?
For maybe five.
These guys are going into battle with thousands.
You can't keep track of them all.
So one of the things that they do,
and this is sort of a,
it's sort of a cover and move scenario.
So the way they set up,
they set up two lines instead of just one line,
they set up two lines back to the book and there should be two lines,
one of them a support the troops in the front line,
we'll fight more eagerly knowing that their rear is protected by the second line
and that their flanks by the flank guards.
So even if you just know you're covered,
man,
you're going to fight harder cause you don't have to worry about what else is
going on.
That's what we do.
Cover and move.
Second,
a man in the first line is not as likely to run away when he knows there are
many other soldiers are stationed to his rear.
That is in his second in the second line.
And we'll see anyone deserted his post.
See there's a little psychological they made.
I'm not going to run cause the guys were right behind me.
They're gonna know in combat.
This can be extremely important.
Supposing that the first line retreats where is pushed back.
Then the second line is there as a support and as a place of refuge,
so he got back each other up.
Cover,
move.
Next one.
A small army should not prepare to face an organized and more numerous foe in
open battle except in case of necessity.
Boom.
Don't go,
go.
Don't go and fight against a bigger battery opponent with more people.
Don't fight against them.
Back to the book.
If the necessity does arise,
do not mass all your troops in front and even if the enemy number is superior,
direct your operations against his rear or his flank for his dangerous and
uncertain and all conditions and against any people to engage purely frontal
combat,
even if the enemy stations is a smaller number of troops upfront.
So this is,
we talk about this over and over again.
Don't attack the front.
Don't attack the the hardened position.
Next squads should be made up of old and young men in proportion.
Otherwise,
the older men,
a formed by themselves may be weak and the younger inexperienced men may turn
out disorganized.
So this is,
uh,
this is obviously important,
but sometimes people have a tendency to want to build a super team,
right?
I'm going to take all of these guys,
all the best guys.
You want to make your teams as even as possible.
This is a classic example.
Don't just take all the old senior guys who have all the experience,
but they might not be in the best physical condition.
I mean,
you take a seagull Petunia,
you know,
you take a a 43 year old seal.
Now there's some studies out there,
don't get me wrong,
but you compare them to a kid that's 24 that's on fire.
You,
that guy's going to be,
you tell that kid to go climb a ladder,
jump up a building,
he's going to do it.
It's there.
They're beasts.
So you want to have both those elements in your team.
And it's the same thing in a bigger organization or a business organization,
spread out the knowledge and spread out.
The enthusiasm is that,
does that have to do with like,
um,
okay.
Are you saying like a senior guy,
he might have a bunch of knowledge versus you know,
a younger guy,
he'll have a lot athleticism and physical capability or in the business world it
could be enthusiasm,
right?
Yeah.
It could be like,
Hey,
I'm just gonna Grind.
Right.
Hunger Young Guy,
my age echo,
I'm going to head home.
You take care of this.
I got it,
boss.
Let's do this.
Is that also because let's say a young guy who has enthusiasm and if you,
if you mix it up with instead of all enthusiastic people,
you have older guys,
they can teach the knowledge to the guy and then yes,
we're going to make our team stronger.
Okay.
Yeah.
Next one,
various tactics and drills.
Constant drill is of the greatest value to the soldier.
Each formation drill should be identified in a special way so that the soldiers
who are trained in these maneuvers may recognize the differences and not be
puzzled by them.
I can't even tell you how much you do what we call in the seal teams that do in
the Marine Corps to do in the army immediate action drills.
So it's contact roles and something goes wrong,
how you're going to maneuver your troops on a battlefield and the more you do
that,
the better you're going to get at it.
The better you get at it,
the better you're gonna perform in combat.
Period.
End of story.
Is that like a fire drill at home?
Yeah,
it's like a fire drill at home.
It's like a fire drill home.
It's like when you drilled Jiu Jitsu,
when you say,
Hey,
I'm going to practice this escape.
Right.
You know,
we do that a lot.
Jeff Glover makes us do that all the time is okay,
let the guy basically put you in a triangle or dean will make you go in triangle
danger,
right?
Or arm locked,
danger,
whatever.
So then you're going to drill,
how are you gonna get out of that?
And that way when you're rolling live,
it's an instinct.
It's the same thing with,
with,
with this situation,
with your military unit.
Yeah.
As soon as you make that simple call flank,
you know,
punch,
right,
move left,
whatever the peel left,
whatever that call that you're gonna make.
Everybody knows what to do and it provides instant organization and focus and
direction to everybody.
Everybody.
It's weird.
You know,
there's certain calls and the seal teams,
certain maneuvers that everybody knows.
If you make one of those calls,
like everyone knows that every single person in the entire seal community knows
exactly what the same thing in the Marine Corps that were me,
there are certain standard operating procedures that you learn in Marine Corps
bootcamp.
If you say it to to a hundred different marines that had been assembled for the
first time ever in their lives.
You say one of these commands,
they're all going to get on it and make it happen.
Yeah.
That's good.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
All right.
Going back to the book strategy,
the points which the general must consider before the day of battle.
A ship cannot cross the sea without a helmsmen,
nor can one defeat an enemy without strategy and tactics with these and the aid
of God,
it is possible to overcome not only an enemy force of equal strength,
but even one greatly superior in numbers for it is not true as some
inexperienced people believe that wars are decided by courage and number of
troops,
but along with God's favor,
by tactics and general ship,
and our concern should be with these rather than wasting our time mobilizing
large numbers of men.
The leader must take advantage of favorable times and places in fighting against
the enemy.
First team must guard against hostile attacks,
which can injure our man and then he must attempt to launch the same against the
enemy.
Above all,
he must look for enemy ambushes,
sending out frequent and far ranging patrols in all directions in the area
around the battlefield.
He must avoid disordered and uncoordinated.
Now this is thinking about what we started this whole thing off.
You get the advantage,
you get the upper hand and battle go finish him,
keep pursuing them until all the enemies completely destroyed.
But he's saying this right here,
he must avoid disordered and uncoordinated pursuits.
Hmm.
Now that my first deployment to Iraq,
there's a couple times we got ambushed.
We are in our vehicles,
got ambushed and the urge is stopped the vehicles.
Let's go get these guys,
and we didn't do that on these particular missions.
We were going,
we had a prize,
some kind of priority target we're going after,
so we're going after a bad guy somewhere.
We make it through.
The ambush evolves and I said,
okay,
stop.
We're going to go get these guys like an ego thing that that would basically be
an ego thing.
Oh,
stop.
Stop.
The vehicle's going to go get these guys.
Not a good call.
We made it through the ambush,
so we were good.
We have a mission to accomplish.
Let's report this up.
The chain of command.
Maybe they can get some aircraft overhead or something like that,
but we're not going to just go into this disorganized pursuit of an enemy that
actually has the upper hand because we made it through that faster.
What else do they have prepared for us?
Because I can guarantee you they want you to stop so you need to think before
you just get overly aggressive.
Back to the book.
We would not allow the general to take part personally in raids or other
reckless attacks.
These should be entrusted to other competent officers for if one of the
subordinate officers,
blunders or fails.
The situation may be quickly straightened out,
but if the leader of the whole army fails this fall can open the way to complete
disorder.
The general is wise who before entering into war,
carefully studies the enemy and can guard against his strong points and take
advantage of his weaknesses.
Obvious stuff that we talk about every single day
back to the book warfare is like hunting.
Wild animals are taken by scouting by nets,
by lying in wait by stalking,
by circling around and buy other stratagems rather than by sheer force.
In waging war.
We should proceed in the same way,
whether the enemy be many or few to try to simply overpower the enemy in the
open hand to hand and face to face.
Even though you might appear to win is an enterprise which is very risky and can
result in serious harm
apart from extreme emergency.
It is ridiculous to try and gain a victory which is so costly and only brings
empty glory.
We're talking about flanking,
we're talking about taking,
always making sure that the cards are stacked in your favor.
Yeah,
that's what we're talking about here.
Okay.
Then it's again,
it applies in life.
It applies any supplies in Jujitsu.
We had a little battle like that today.
You were called.
I was.
I was actually,
did you see me smiling?
I was like kind of laughing because you were boom coming at me,
coming at me and I was,
I was,
I was kind of laughing cause I was thinking about this podcast and I was
thinking,
Hey,
he's going head to head with me face to face and I'm going to find them.
But that's,
that's the way it works.
Been gently.
Yeah,
apparently.
All right.
Back to the book.
On the actual day of the battle,
the general should not take on too many tasks.
He might exert himself too much,
become worn out and overlook some really essential matters.
Now,
that to me is number one,
you got to detach.
And number two,
you don't want to be in the weeds.
If you're trying to get everything you've done yourself,
you're going to overlook some really essential matters.
He should not look downcast or worried,
but should ride gently along the lines and encourage all troops.
He should not himself join in the actual fighting.
This is not the role of the general but of the soldier.
After making all the proper arrangements,
he should stationed himself in a suitable spot from which he can observe which
troops are exerting themselves and which might be slacking when needed.
He should be ready to send assistance to a unit in trouble by making use of his
reserves.
That is the flank and rear guards.
So you got to stay detached.
So when we're talking to general here,
this is the general,
this is the CEO,
right?
This is the president of a company not getting so far into the weeds that you
just don't see what's happening and you can't.
If you're in the weeds fighting,
who's going to be watching to see that?
That area slackening who was going to be able to direct the rear guard to help
out who's going to send the reinforcements answers.
Nobody does.
You're not doing your job.
Here's another one.
Even though the general decides against a pitched battle,
he should still make preparations for one
gotta be ready.
Somebody asked me actually on Twitter a couple of days ago,
are you worried about another nine 11 in America?
And I said,
I'm not worried.
Yeah,
I'm prepared.
And that's what this is saying.
Even you,
even though you don't want to do a pitch battle mess,
I'm not gonna meet them.
Hey,
that's,
that's too much of a frontal attack.
I'm not going to do that.
You better be ready for one.
That might be the only choice might get attacked.
What you,
you've got to always be ready to back to the book.
He should make it appear that he plans on one and convey the impression to all
his troops that he will definitely attack the enemy.
This will cause trouble for the enemy when it comes to their knowledge.
So you,
you've got to prepare.
Be prepared.
No slack.
Another one here.
This is about infantry drill movements that we're going back to training here.
Yeah,
the Herald commands silence.
Observe orders,
do not worry.
Keep your position,
follow the standard.
Do not leave the standard and pursue the enemy.
The troops then advance at a steady pace and in silence without anyone even
whispering,
they should become accustomed to these movements so that as a spoken command on
nod or some other signal,
they march or Holt,
reduce or divide the depth of the files march steadily in close order for a good
distance over various kinds of terrain.
Close or tighten their ranks in depth and width.
March,
engage in mock battle,
sometimes using staffs and sometimes naked sorts.
So this is,
this is a really important one.
This is,
this is reminds me very much of something that we used to do.
So he's saying you're going to do a drill right and you're not allowed to talk.
You have to be completely silent.
And this is something we absolutely used to drill us in the seal teams where
you're not allowed to talk.
And we would actually sometimes take radios away.
So hey you can we turn off,
hey everyone,
turn off your radios.
So you just have to figure this out.
And if you run like that all the time,
eventually everybody returns.
How it makes everyone more proactive because you know you're not going to hear a
command,
you know the boss isn't gonna go on the radio and say flank left you.
That's not coming.
Cause that's,
so you have to learn to look around.
You have to learn to sense what's going to happen.
And it makes everybody better at what they're doing.
And I'll tell you,
you know,
I've talked about this before.
We didn't in my task and my platoon,
we didn't talk on the radio.
We didn't,
we barely talked on the radio.
If,
if I came on the radio and said something,
it was everybody was scoped,
the jock would just talked her,
you know,
life would say to me,
Jacqueline,
moving to building 48 that's say do it.
They'd go,
they wouldn't,
he,
he did Roger and he'd go,
they wouldn't say anything else.
And that was because when we were in training,
we would do these drills where we wouldn't talk.
You're not allowed to talk.
You're allowed to make a head nod.
You're allowed to give somebody of a visual signal,
but you're not allowed to come on the radio and you're not allowed to talk.
And that makes you so good.
It what it does is it makes your verbal,
your nonverbal communication skills on point.
It was cool when I went to officer candidate school.
So at officer candidate school,
they got a little things that they do to you.
And I'll give you a couple examples.
One of them is you're not allowed to look at your food when you're eating.
So you,
you have to stare straight ahead.
And this doesn't sound like a big deal cause you think to yourself,
well I'll just look at my food,
right?
If you look at your food,
everybody can see it in the drill.
Instructors come over to start and look at your food.
You're not supposed to get food.
So what you have to do is you have to just look straight ahead.
You're looking straight ahead across the table and you're just guessing where
your food is pretty much stabbing your fork into the tray of food that you have
in front of you and it's,
you know,
it's a little hard to eat and then over time you start to be able to utilize
your peripheral vision a little bit more so that you can see it without looking
at it.
That's one.
The other one,
I think I've talked about this,
you have to scream everything that you say,
right?
There's so there's all these little things that they make.
You do go ballistic,
go ballistic at all times,
right?
It's,
I've told that story before.
But when it was pretty cool when,
when my drill instructor,
Gunnery Sergeant,
Marine Corps,
Awesome Guy,
when we got done,
you know,
he was explaining why we did all this stuff in the one about not looking at your
food comes from him.
It does come from improving your peripheral vision because the way the officer
candidate school was originally set up was for pilots,
potential navy pilots.
So guess what?
You got to be able to see your instruments down below you while you're looking
around and scanning for enemy aircraft.
And so this is what it does is it allows you to improve.
Well this is the same thing when when you build that muscle memory of hey,
I'm not going to talk and I need to look around and I need to be mentally
proactive and make sure that I,
I'm not going to hear anything.
So as a junior guy,
I have to look around,
I have to make a decision,
I have to absorb and figure out what's happening.
That is unbelievably good.
So anybody that works in an environment,
you know,
police officers,
obviously military do these silent drills doing them,
it'll make you that much better.
You know,
it's funny,
I was just relaying the mats at our gym the other day and Andy was there,
big Andy by the way,
just got his black belt by the way.
Yeah,
we relay in the maths and you know he's just a,
we're just working and we didn't say a word to each other for five hours.
We're there,
we're just picking up stuff and doing stuff.
And you know,
he's an,
he's an iron worker by trade and so he just guy that,
you know,
just,
he sees me doing something he's doing,
I see him doing something.
What is non verbal communication?
Just nonverbal communication work on it.
It's awesome.
All right,
so this next section is,
is really kind of where I was heading with all this.
This is the,
these are maxims,
right?
General instructions and maxims.
And when we do books that are maximums,
it makes my job really easy because I'm not trying to pull stuff out.
It's there.
They already pulled it out for you.
You know,
we didn't.
Napoleon's maximums,
there's nothing to pull out.
Read the maxims.
Boom,
San Suu auto war.
Oh,
there's nothing to pull out.
Read the maxims.
And that's what this rolls into right here.
Different.
And in one of the things I talk about this in Jujitsu,
I talk about this in any,
in anything.
So these maxims,
you're going to see,
these are familiar.
So why would we go film again?
Why do we need to hear them again?
I'll tell you the reason why we need to hear him again.
Because just like Jujitsu,
you are going to see these things from a slightly different angle every single
time.
Just like in combat,
you're going to enter,
you're going to enter a million rooms as an assaulter on an assault team.
You're gonna enter a million different rooms and there's a basic structured,
all of them.
But no two rooms are alike.
No two rooms are exactly like,
and the more that you enter and the more different angles you see,
the better you get at handling them.
Just like in Jujitsu,
when you go against different body types,
the better you get at your arm locks.
When you do on a mock from the bottom,
from the top,
from the side,
you get better at those arm locks.
In the business world,
the more deals that you see and you understand how they unfold,
the better you're going to get.
The construction industry,
the more walls you build,
there are a little bit different.
Little things come out a little bit different.
So the more you see them,
the more you hear them from slightly different angles,
the more adept you are utilizing them.
That's why I love when I see these maxims.
So
here we go.
General instructions for the commander
in carrying out very critical operations.
The general ought not set himself apart as though such labor was beneath him,
but he should begin the work and toil along with his troops as much as possible.
Such behavior will lead the soldier to be more submissive to his officers,
even if only out of shame and he will accomplish more so.
So even though,
you know earlier saying,
hey,
general don't,
don't get in the weeds,
but if there's work to do,
do the work,
show them you're doing the work.
Yeah.
Next twin,
certain offenses are common among the soldiers.
Moderation is called four.
Do not judge and punish all indiscriminately.
Widespread resentment might draw them all together and discipline would become
even worse.
It is wiser to punish just a few of the ring leaders.
So we,
you can talk about the harshness of the Roman Legion,
but here he's saying,
look,
[inaudible],
dial that back a little bit.
Dial that back a little bit.
If the offense is our common among the soldiers.
So when you,
this is,
you know,
this is also a little bit of Leif Babin.
Uh,
it's not what you preach.
It's what you tolerate.
If you're tolerating it,
then you can't just all of a sudden drop the hammer because you're going to look
inconsistent.
If you're not going to tolerate it,
don't tolerate it.
But if you do,
and it's a common offense,
don't all of a sudden fly off the handle inconsistent.
Next,
the generals a way of life.
Should be plain and simple like that of his soldiers.
He should display a fatherly affection toward them.
He should give orders in a mild manner and he should always make sure to give
advice and to discuss essential matters with them in person.
So this is,
we heard this from pat and we hear this from everybody,
but patents said that exact same thing,
right?
You need to do that.
You need to live like your soldiers.
We hear that all the time.
Dick winters said,
everybody says this,
don't,
don't go up in there.
Don't go up in the ivory tower.
Don't do it,
boss,
man.
So like the boss who gets the huge corner,
everyone has cubicles as a huge gold plated stuff.
Yeah.
The way the massage chair in the office don't disturb me,
12 minutes,
I'm running the 12 minute massage cheer session.
His concerns ought to be with their safety,
their food,
and their regular pay.
Without these,
it is impossible to maintain discipline in an army
by being just in punishing offenders.
He should instill fear at the very first sign of a disciplinary problem.
He should take action to end it.
And not delay dealing with it until it grows or becomes more serious.
The general successful when his men regard him as unshakeable and just,
yeah,
you should also see that civilians are left on harmed.
Boom.
So when you got the problem,
when you see the problem,
get the problem solved.
Don't wait.
It's not going to go away.
It's not going to get,
not going to get better on its own.
Next,
he should be temperant in his way of life and vigilant.
Okay?
Pretty straightforward.
It's a maxim.
Next,
it is essential to be cautious and take your time in making plans.
And once you have come to a decision to carry it out right away without any
hesitation,
timidity after all is not caution,
but the invention of wickedness when you're going to go,
go,
go.
Once you make your decision,
go that a default aggressive,
that is a default aggressive thing.
Yes,
I,
healthy mind is not unduly elated by success or overly depressed when things are
not going well.
A lot of these speak for themselves.
That's one of them.
You gotta be mentally road maintain.
Don't get emotional,
not a lady to,
we would not to prove through loss,
no maintain.
Next,
it is safer and more advantageous to overcome the enemy by planning in general
ship than by sheer force.
In the one case,
results are achieved without loss to oneself while on the other.
Some price has to be paid.
Next,
it is very important to spread rumors among the enemy that you are planning to
do one thing and then go do something else.
Your plans about major operations should not be known to many,
but just a few and those very close to you.
Next
alarming rumors or traps of treachery,
whether on the part of the enemy on her own ought not be neglected or action
differed,
but steps should be taken to deal with them and put a shop stop to them before
they become realities.
You start hearing rumors smash him.
That's one thing I see in companies companies.
This is a problem that businesses have.
I mean it happens in the military you,
but businesses have this problem where they,
they let rumors grow,
they let messaging get formed.
By the uninformed.
And that's not what you want to do.
If you're in charge of a business and something bad is going to happen,
explain it to everyone.
Don't let the people explain it themselves because the idea that they're going
to come up with is gonna be the worst case scenario possible that they can
imagine.
So proactive communications so people know what is happening.
Don't let them define their own messaging and their own rumors.
Stop them by giving them the information.
Next,
the enemy's should be
deceived by false reports of our plans brought to them by deserters from us.
So you got people that you think might leave you cool.
Give him some bad intel.
Hmm.
Courage should be roused and our troops by fabricating report of a victory over
the enemy,
one by our men someplace else.
Now this is a controversial in my mind,
right?
So what they're saying is,
hey,
you should make up some stories about how well so-and-so's doing in another area
that you've got to think about what you're doing there.
And of course,
in this day and age,
that's hard to do.
We have just opened communications.
We have texting,
we have phones,
we have all this stuff.
So it's,
you'd be hard pressed to verify that.
But one of the things that I thought about when I read that where I disagree
with this is in mixed martial arts for instance,
guy loses around in,
you know,
round one.
The guy goes out and doesn't do a good job is losing the round,
comes back to his corner.
What does his corner tell him?
You're doing great.
Keep it going.
That's the wrong worst thing you can do.
Worst thing you can do is lie to like,
cause he'll keep,
you'll keep it.
Keep doing that.
Keep it up.
All right.
Yeah.
You need to say,
look,
you're losing in anytime it's close.
You've got to assume that the other guy won any round that's even remotely
close.
You've got assume the other guy got that round.
Yeah,
so don't do this.
Don't say great round.
Keep it going.
No,
there's not a single MMA fighters that I've ever worked with that when you tell
them great round,
you're winning steps it up.
I'd never seen,
I've never heard it.
Never seen it.
Never heard it.
And if you watch the UFC because they got those corner cams now,
and I have the Internet thing where I can pick who I'm going to listen to and I
can rewatch and you can hear what the corners are saying to you,
check it out,
go and look at a fighter who's corner tells them they're doing a great job and
tell me,
find me an example of where a guy hears he's doing a great job and then he steps
it up.
Well,
even harder,
it doesn't happen.
Everybody goes into cruise mode and if they're losing,
guess what?
That cruise mode that gets them destroyed.
So be careful with that one.
Marise gotta disagree with you on that one.
Back to the book.
News about reverses suffered by us should be kept secret and report stating just
the opposite should be circulated about.
Okay,
so now we're talking about controlling,
controlling the messaging,
but we're talking about lying and in this day and age doesn't work,
you get it doesn't not going to work for you.
You can't say don't worry about it.
It was like,
remember Baghdad Bob?
When we went into Baghdad and he,
there's American tanks,
m one Abrams Rolling in crushing and music go.
We've got the Americans on the run.
Yeah,
we're running down your front door.
So this is not,
this isn't going to work,
right?
What you need to do is if reverses happen,
you need to come out.
You need to own them.
You need to explain what happened and you need to get ahead of them and don't
let the rumor mill turn into something worse than it is.
You might be able to mitigate it.
Don't lie about it.
I'm not going to get you anywhere.
Next defeated troop should not be allowed to fall into despair,
but they should be dealt with by stirring up hope by various other means.
Common Sense.
Next during combat,
one has to overlook offenses committed by the soldiers,
but afterward,
get rid of men.
Guilty of sedition,
which is like someone that's going to rebel against you.
Again,
this is very,
this is a questionable,
right?
If you,
during combat,
if you start overlooking offenses,
guess what?
You're gonna end up with my mee Lai massacre.
That's what you're gonna end up with.
No,
stop them.
Disagree.
Marise sorry.
When you have a situation like that happening,
you need to stop it.
Yeah.
You need to put an end to it.
Now,
that being said,
are you gonna Hound on every little thing that happens?
No.
Right?
Maybe you're going to give a little bit of slack with
something that's pretty meaningless,
right?
Maybe give a little bit of slack at the same time.
You can't just,
you've got to give you guys some room.
That's what I'm saying.
You've got to give you guys some room.
You got to hold the line.
Absolutely.
You've got to hold the line,
but you can't freak out because you got bigger than you should.
Definitely have bigger things to worry about.
Then this little item,
right?
Let's just,
Hey,
get that tightened up.
Yeah,
let's move on.
Let's not focus on it.
Not going to fire you because you made a mistake.
Yeah.
Next.
Our own dead should be buried secretly at night,
but the enemies should be left out there as a means of making them lose courage.
Good psychological warfare.
Okay.
Next.
When a delegation comes from the enemy,
inquire about the leaders of the group and on their arrival,
treat them very friendly,
so their own people will come to suspect them.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of little crafty little psychological warfare that they do,
and that's one of them.
Act like,
you know this enemy.
Make the enemy look at him like,
how's this?
Why is,
why is Jocko being so nice to echo right here?
They're acting like they're old friends.
You're going to get suspicious of you.
That's what I'm trying to do.
Cause some divide.
Plant the seat.
Yes.
Acts of cowardice on the part of our soldiers should be kept quiet and not
publicly condemned since this may make them even worse.
Again,
we're talking about a communication thing and you're not going to be able to,
you're not gonna be able to keep that stuff under wraps.
People are gonna know.
Yeah.
So get ahead of it.
Next away of arousing discord and suspicion among the enemy is to refrain from
burning or plundering the estates of certain prominent men on their side and
have them alone.
So going,
like I said,
go into the village,
burn everyone's house except echoes and you're like the prominent guy and they
go,
hey,
what's up?
How come you didn't burn your house?
No,
I'm not friends with them.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Really?
We're going to come back.
I want to kill you.
Yeah,
like the,
like the cops,
right.
They do that where
they'll apprehend some guy in the cartel,
I don't know.
Whatever,
the drug gang.
Yup.
And then there'll be like,
okay,
bye.
Like,
oh they wait,
you got arrested?
Nothing happened to you in the like,
oh no,
it's all good.
Okay.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's exactly it.
Next one way of getting a besieged city to submit is by sending letters tied to
arrows,
promising freedom and immunity.
This can also be done by releasing prisoners.
Cool.
Next.
Great caution must be observed and pursuing the enemy over ground suited for
ambush was a good general turn back at the right time.
So we can come back later to attack more effectively.
That's why I'm not stopping my patrol to go back and attack an ambush that just
got through their ground,
may have it.
The waiting for us in prompt to split.
They have the advantage.
They have it.
They'd been waiting there.
Every art of war,
every maximum ward will tell you,
you want to have the upper hand.
You want to pick the battlefield.
They picked it.
Yeah.
Don't get into a scrap of them right there.
Hmm.
Next,
do not be deceived by humane acts of the enemy or by they're pretending to
retreat.
Next,
cowardly officers are recognized by their hesitation and pallor during combat.
They should be assigned to exhilarate forces.
Notice that he is using them right.
Just because someone's a coward,
he's still got work for them.
You go and run the logistics,
you know that's okay because I need bodies.
I need people.
When a populous city is taken is important to leave the gates open so that the
inhabitants may escape and not be driven to utter desperation.
The same holds on an enemy's fortified campus taken.
So we want to give people an out so that they don't fight to the death.
And this is very common with the ego,
Huh?
You don't,
you don't,
I don't trap you and prove you wrong in the room,
right?
I don't live in a big meeting.
I don't go and go,
here's the four reasons why you're completely wrong and they're indisputable.
No,
I give you a little out.
I see echo,
you know,
have found these things and I think this might be a better way to do it.
And by the way,
this also happens and this other thing,
so maybe we could adjust your plan a little bit and do it here.
Now if you have any sense whatsoever,
you see all four of those reasons and you go,
yeah,
let's go ahead and do that.
Jocko.
That's a good call.
And I say,
no problem boss,
and we're good.
But if I come in there and start making you look like a jackass,
you're totally wrong.
Your system doesn't work.
You're going to dig in on that.
Now we got issues,
now you're fighting to the death.
I'm going backwards
next.
Even in friendly territory,
afford a camp should be set up.
A general should never have to say,
I did not expect it.
Even in friendly territory.
Be ready
for a safe retreat.
Build a fire in one place and go off quietly to another.
The enemy will head to the fire.
Deception.
Next letter's ought to be sent out to designers from our side who have joined
the enemy in such a way that the letters will fall into the enemy's hands.
These letters should remind the designers of the prearranged time for their
treachery so that the enemy will become suspicious of them.
They'll have to flee.
That's a crafty little move.
Crafty little move.
Oh,
Echo,
you deserted us and hey,
we'll meet you at this night so you can give us the information you told us
you're going to give us.
They hang you.
Traitor.
Next,
when it comes to dangerous or surprise,
operations,
cowards could be weeded out if all the men who are sick or who's horses are too
weak or ordered to fall out.
Yeah.
The cowards,
we'll then claim to be six and so they can be separated from the others.
They can be assigned to guard fortresses or some other duty involving little
danger.
That's a good tactic.
You think about that back in the day.
Hey guys,
if anyone's not feeling good followed over here cause we,
you know,
you're not 100% so we don't want to bring you in this operation.
The cowards go away.
I'm a little bit sick feeling a little under the weather.
Okay,
cool.
You go guard the rear.
Is that cause like in a way they're not hundred percent either,
right?
Yeah.
Their cowardice a month and you're giving them an out.
Cause they're not gonna.
They might not say anything,
but then at the moment of truth,
they're not there to back you up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So you give a little out,
hey,
if you're not feeling good,
go over here in this line.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
you're over there a coward,
but I'm still gonna utilize you.
Yeah.
Next.
We should not furnish arms to those who promise to fight on our side because
their real intentions are not clear.
This is something America as a nation should get very familiar with.
We should not furnish arms to those who promised to fight on our side because
their real intentions are not clear.
We give away arms in a ridiculous manner.
Ridiculous manner.
Yeah.
And we should,
because the real intentions are not clear.
Next after a victory,
we must not become careless,
but be on our guard.
All the more against surprise attacks by the vanquished.
Just because you won doesn't mean,
and this is,
you know Jeff eggs,
right?
Yes.
So this is something Higgs taught me like years ago.
I'm talking blue belt in Jujitsu.
Higgs do Jujitsu.
He's a seal.
He,
he got out of the seal teams,
he got totally into Jujitsu and the one of the original guys I trained with with
master chief Steve Bailey back in the day.
So anyways,
we were rolling one day and we were talking and he said,
if you tap somebody,
you got to go harder because they're going to go hard.
So if you,
you know,
and I'm,
I mean someone that you battle with,
right,
right.
Someone that you battle with and all of a sudden you get them better step up
your game because they're going to go harder.
Yeah.
Same thing right here.
You get a storm.
Yeah.
You gotta Watch yourself.
Off.
Like if you're running the mile,
you know,
like in track your running the mile,
he pull away out of Hit,
right.
And you're like,
oh I'm,
you know,
this last lap,
whatever,
you know,
I'm just going to can it,
yeah.
Ready?
You got to step it up.
Cause that guy that you've been beating,
vanquished whatever.
Yeah.
You know,
he's coming,
he's coming next on voice from the enemy must not be treated disrespectfully
even when our forces are much stronger.
Next,
an army,
no matter how strong besieging the city must never leave its own camp unguarded.
Nor should it think that fortifications are sufficient to assure its safety.
But she keeps sending out patrols.
Don't ever let your guard down saying this over and over again.
Next suspected defectors should be told the opposite of what we intend to do so
that we may use them to deceive the enemy.
And treachery must be guarded against even during periods of truce or temporary
piece.
Next,
by no means should we believe reports that come from deserves or defectors
alone,
but their reports should be checked against statements made by prisoners taken
in raids.
And in this way,
that truth may be discerned.
So you got to check with all the different sources.
And this is something that the intelligence community does extremely well,
which is they take all these different little chunks of information and they
assemble it together into a picture.
You know,
we've seen those pictures where it's just like a bunch of dots when you look at
it up close,
but then when you step back,
it's something real.
Yeah.
That's why these intelligence,
these intelligence communities,
do,
they take all those little dots,
it seems like a meaningless dot.
Just a meaningless little dot.
But they're going to put it on that broad picture and it's going to fill in one
little piece of information that they need.
You put all that stuff together and all of a sudden they know who you are,
they know where to attack.
Yeah.
And that kind of makes sense there where it's like some dessert or somebody who
basically doesn't have credibility.
Right.
So they'll be like,
hey,
he's not necessarily lying,
but he could be silly.
He becomes real circumstantial,
you know?
And then like how you're saying,
you put all the dots together and yet for some reason this dot it's not fitting.
It's not painting a picture,
but then you know,
okay,
he's wishy washy anyway.
So,
oh,
I see he's lying right now.
You know what I mean?
Line about that piece,
but maybe didn't lie about another piece.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Next,
in no way should a sworn agreement made with the enemy be broken.
So if you,
you need to hold,
hold,
hold your work.
Even with the enemy.
Hold your word
next after God,
we should place our hopes of safety in our weapons,
not in our fortifications alone.
Don't just count on the defense.
Next orders should be given to the soldiers that they should be ready to march
out on a holiday in the rain day or night.
For this reason,
they should not be told the time or day beforehand.
So they may always be prepared.
Hmm.
This is,
this reminded me of when my last deployment to Iraq and you're winding down and
I told my guys,
I said,
Hey,
I'm not going to tell you guys when we're going to stop operations.
Like we're just going to stop cause I didn't want ADB going out thinking this is
the last operation.
Just play it safe.
Does it?
Hey guys,
when,
when we're done with I'll loop,
you know,
but just keep going.
Yeah.
Kaiser,
look,
Roger that.
Yeah,
keep going.
And then one day we got done.
Yeah,
but to keep the mentality of,
you know,
don't think about,
this is going to be the last operation.
You don't want them cruising and it's not the finish line.
Right.
Next risks should be taken without necessity or real hope of gain.
Sorry.
Risks should not be taken without necessity or real hope of gain
to do so is the same as fishing with gold as bait.
Next inhabitants of the area who seek refuge should not be received
indiscriminately.
Often enough,
they'd been sent by the enemy deceit deceitfully to plot against their hosts.
This is something we ran into a lot in Ramadi where people are acting normal and
they knew our rules of engagement and so they knew like before they didn't have
a gun,
they weren't going to shoot him.
Yeah.
And so they would do things,
they'd probe and they'd see how close he could get and see where we were.
So just because these people are coming with their hands up doesn't mean they're
are innocent.
You know,
they might not be guilty,
they might not be innocent either.
Next,
we should also be on our guard against deserved.
As who approach a besieged city.
Often enough,
they are sent by the enemy to set fires so that while the defenders are busy
putting them out,
the enemy may have tax him.
Just be cautious.
Troops defeated.
An open battle should not be pampered.
Or even if it seems like a good idea,
take refuge in a fortified camp or some other strong place,
but while their fear is still fresh,
they should attack again
by not indulging them.
Yeah,
may they may
with greater assurance renew the fighting.
It's don't take care of them.
You can't just say,
oh,
we beat you,
so come on in the camp and relax.
No,
not happening.
Next,
if the general thinks he's ready to meet the enemy in battle,
he should get set to carry on the fighting in the enemy's country instead of his
own men waging war in a foreign land become more aggressive.
They will also feel that the war in which they are engaged is not only being
fought on behalf of their country,
but also their own personal safety.
This is not necessarily the case if the war is fought in their own land in which
the existence of fortresses eliminates the risks to men since in case of flight,
they may easily take refuge in them.
There's a little bit different than what we might deal with today because today
we deploy to some country and fight.
That's not your homeland.
Yeah.
So you're saying,
Nah,
you know what?
This is this.
You know,
I don't have to defend this.
And can you imagine if America got invaded?
How hard the Americans would fight?
Yeah.
No one could ever pull it off.
It would be too hard.
Because once the Americans say,
Oh,
you're going to think you're going to take my country wouldn't have anything,
any happening.
Not Happening.
Yeah.
Go try and take someone's parking space in America.
Here.
You're there ready to kill you.
So you think you're going to take land from us.
Not Happening.
Not going to happen.
So there's a little bit different,
but the mentality of being aggressive and in what,
what I think what the mentality is talking about is knowing that you can retreat
knowing that you can go back to your fortress.
So that means,
you know,
in this day and age,
or sorry,
in that era,
they knew they couldn't,
they didn't have any.
All they could do was fight.
They had to win.
You know what?
This is a great comparison is in the,
in the old school navy,
you had no choice.
You have no choice on a naval vessel,
you have no choice but to fight.
You have no choice because if your ship gets sunk,
you're dead in the hall,
in the on the ground,
you can run away,
you can hide,
you can retreat,
you can fall back.
Where do you fall back to you on a ship that's being attacked.
You don't go on the ocean and you die.
So that's one of the kind of core things.
That's old school navy.
You cannot retreat.
You cannot give up.
You can't use.
There's an order to surrender.
You can't surrender.
It's if you surrender,
you die.
If you don't fight with everything you got,
So you have no choice but to fight until you're dead.
That's kind of the mentality of the old school navy.
Nowhere to run to.
You can't,
can't retreat.
Can't fall back.
You're there.
Yeah.
So that little section was called V,
the general instructions for the commander and now we get into the straight up
maxims.
First one,
the man who spends more sleepless nights with his army and who works harder in
drilling his troops,
runs the fewest risks in fighting the fall.
Self evident
reminds me of majorly in colder than hell,
who remember there?
They're like patrolling to combat and he's got the guys doing drills getting
after it
next,
never lead soldiers into combat before they,
before having made sufficient trial of their courage.
So why we train hard next,
it is well to hurt the enemy by deceit,
by raids,
or by hunger,
and never be enticed into a pitch battle,
which is demonstration more of luck than of bravery.
So he's saying a pitched battle is like there's luck is luck.
Yeah.
What's the pitch?
Pitch.
Battle.
Face to face.
Yeah.
Okay.
Next.
Only those battle plans are successful,
which the enemy does not suspect before we put them into action.
Next,
the deception is often helpful in warfare and enemy soldier who deserts us apart
from some plot is of the greatest advantage for enemy is hurt by deserters more
than if the same man or killed in action.
Next.
He who does not care fully compare his own forces with those,
the enemy will come to a disastrous end.
Here's a good one for you.
Courage and discipline are able to accomplish more than a large number of
warriors.
Often enough,
the lay of the land has been helpful in making the weaker force come out on top
terrain.
Those of you in the military terrain,
learn how to read terrain.
Learn how to use terrain.
Learn how to figure out the high ground burnout out where the dead spaces are.
Learn where the ravines are that puts you in a bit better firing position.
Okay,
next nature produces,
but a few brave men,
whereas care and training make efficient soldiers,
soldiers who are kept working,
improve,
encourage.
I'm going to say that again.
Soldiers who are kept working improve in courage while too much leisure makes
them weak and lazy.
Next things which are unexpected or sudden frightened the enemy,
but they pay little attention to things to which they are accustomed.
Hm?
Used to that
after gaining a victory,
a general who pursues the enemy with a scattered and disorganized army gives
away his victory.
To his foe
and here's a simple one,
but because of war must be just,
hmm.
Next.
It does not help to assemble the whole army in council or to keep sending for
men when they are off duty.
These things only cause discord in the army.
I put that one in there because this applies to business a lot where all of a
sudden you're calling that person all the weekend.
Nice meeting another meeting.
I need to talk to everyone.
Okay.
On their off day.
Burn them out.
Be careful with that.
Next,
the soldiers must always be doing something even if no enemy is bothering us.
Habitual idleness spells trouble for an army.
So those two are kind of contradictory.
Bailed on me calling people all the time,
but keeping busy,
we've got to figure out how we separate in the business world.
How do you separate work from life and as the boss,
you got to make that distinction.
Yeah.
It kind of seems like that makes sense.
I mean consider like exercise or something.
Like you got to have the recovery period.
Yes.
I can't be just cruising,
skipping days all the time.
You know,
so it's like that.
What do you,
what do you call it in the,
uh,
in the deal dichotomy.
There's a dichotomy.
Yes.
Yeah.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Next full.
What should be done?
Seek the advice of many for what you will actually do.
Take counsel with only a few trustworthy people.
Then off by yourself alone.
Decide on the best and most helpful plan to follow and stick to it.
Hey everyone,
tell me what's going on.
Give me your ideas.
Yeah.
Okay,
great.
A little bit smaller group.
Okay guys,
there's the input we got,
we think and then guess what?
The commanders gotta make a decision.
You can weigh all those different inputs,
but the commander has got to make a decision.
Yeah.
And when you make the decision,
you got to own it.
Now,
one thing that's interesting,
and I don't mean to go on too much of a tangent here,
but I'll make a decision
and execute with aggression,
but my mind is not closed.
And if I go say we're going to do x and we start executing x and x is not
looking good,
I'll say,
stop executing X.
I was wrong.
Here's what we're going to do.
So just because you're being decisive doesn't mean that you're being stupid.
Just because you're being decisive doesn't mean you're not.
You're,
you're losing your plasticity.
We don't lose our plasticity.
Even when we make a hard decision,
even when I say this is what we're going to do,
my mind is still open and again,
a lot of times I'll try and break as a leader.
I will try and break big decisions into smaller incremental decisions that allow
me to change course during the execution and you know for for,
and I've told them,
I've said this something like this before,
but if we got a bad guy target and we think the bad guy is going to be there,
the first thing that I tell dude,
dude,
tell the guys to start planning.
So they're going to start planning.
Then I might put them,
okay guys,
we're going to,
we're going to go and put you guys in the staging area.
Well,
they execute,
we're executing,
but we're not executing.
Right.
All you're doing is going to a staging area.
Yeah.
Then I might even put a reconnaissance element out to watch the target we're
executing,
but we're not executing.
I could still say,
okay,
stop everyone come back home.
We don't think he's there.
We don't think it's a good mission.
We think it's a trap or whatever.
So I gave,
I committed,
I made a decision,
we're going to hit this target,
but I made that decision incrementally.
I didn't just say we're going to hit it and now no matter what happens,
so a lot of times as a leader,
I look at all the big decision,
okay,
yeah,
that's a big decision and I'm going to be decisive on it,
but I'm going to make incremental progress towards that decision.
That way I can be adaptable.
As I moved towards that execution,
the very important lesson to learn,
very important lesson to learn.
I never just jump off the cliff.
It's like you're creating a point of no return,
right?
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a last point of cover and concealment is an actual term that we use.
Last point of covering.
So that means there's a target.
And once you cross this line,
now you actually do have to go.
Now get your,
you're out in the open.
They can see you.
Yeah,
do or die.
So that's the point.
But that point should come soul far down the road that you can execute the
target.
You can execute the target,
you can execute the target,
but you still haven't actually executed until you've gone past that last point
of cover and concealment.
Once you're there,
once you go pass the last point in covering concealment,
you're done.
You have to go.
But that should be very late in the game.
And it's the same thing in the business world.
Oh,
we want to,
we want to open up into this new market.
Okay,
let's do a reconnaissance.
That market you're executing.
But you might do reconnaissance the market and say,
you know what?
It's not what we thought it was going to be.
Stop.
Okay,
let's get a building.
So now are you going to lease?
We're going to buy you don't go in there and buy a building cause we don't want
to own that thing yet.
We don't know the terrain well enough.
We're going to lease a building.
Guess what we're doing?
We do an eight year lease.
No,
no,
no.
We're doing a two year lease.
We're just gonna slowly execute incrementally cause we might get in there and
say,
ah,
it's not looking good.
Right?
So think about how you can break these major decisions down into smaller
incremental decisions that give you the adaptability.
Next.
If an enemy spy has captured while observing our forces that it may well be
maybe well to release him on harm.
If all our forces are strong and in good shape,
the enemy will absolutely does be dismayed by such reports.
On the other hand,
if our forces are weak,
the spine should be treated roughly forced to divulge,
divulge enemies secrets and finally either be put to death or sent off elsewhere
under guard,
obviously we don't put our prisoners to deaf anymore.
But you know what's interesting about this in in the business world,
and I've worked with all kinds of different companies and the reason I keep
talking about this spy stuff and the captured and is because every industry,
every industry out there,
they are constantly competing for people.
And whether it's this,
uh,
technology companies,
whether it's financial companies,
they're always trying to recruit each other and to try and get this guy to leave
and they're trying to pull this person over every different.
A lot of times I work with companies,
they don't realize that all of the companies are like this.
There's only the,
you know,
they say,
well,
you know,
the thing is we get,
we,
we people are trying to recruit our people all the time.
Yes,
it happens in every industry.
Every industry has got people trying to recruit their people.
And that's why I'm talking about this stuff.
Because if you think about it,
if you know someone's going to go to another company,
let's give them some bad intelligence before they leave.
You know,
let's say that,
oh,
we're thinking we're working.
We're not going to go into that market.
Let them know that you are going in and out market by the way.
Full speed.
Yeah.
So that's why I'm saying this again.
You know,
you'd get to this point where,
you know,
as a,
as a upstanding human being,
let's be straight up with people.
But I'm assuming now that someone has maybe done you wrong,
you know,
they,
they're trying to take clients,
they're trying to take business away from your business.
He's now we're getting into a little bit of a,
we had a little some hostilities or brewing,
so some psychological warfare game within the game,
within the game.
And there's a game within the game.
And again,
you have to maintain your integrity as a,
as a human.
And then that's,
that is definitely for me,
the,
the absolute primary thing,
right?
It's to maintain your integrity.
They're not maintaining your integrity with you.
We,
maybe they're going to get some misinformation on the way out the door.
Sorry.
That's the way it works.
And they'll name the other one problem.
But you know,
I'm,
I'll,
I'll kind of draw back on that a little bit and I'll tell you why.
One of the best things about when someone leaves the company,
one of the best things you can do is treat them good as they leave.
Yeah.
Really cause that,
cause when they show up at that new company that made all these promises to them
that are not true and they're looking back and going,
man,
you know,
Jocko was just honest with me and he told me he wanted me to stay and he told me
that,
you know,
we're going to grow and he told me he didn't have an opportunity right now but
we'll find in the future.
He believes me.
Yeah.
So I'm going to actually retract my statement about using these kinds of,
you know,
putting your integrity at risk.
It's better to maintain your integrity and,
and it might not be better instantly,
but in the long run you're going to be better off even with like a spy
situation.
So,
I mean kind of considered,
if you were to draw the analogy of a spy,
like let's say a tamp came in,
your co come to me and he's really a spy because he's attempt somewhere else,
I don't know,
whatever.
And you find out or you get,
you know,
like information,
whatever that that leads you to believe all that guy's the spy.
Right.
And then you start essentially lying to them about projects or I don't know,
whatever goals.
Yeah,
I'd probably just get rid of them.
I'd probably just say treat them nice.
I'd be like,
hey listen,
I don't think you're here for the best reasons.
Yeah.
And in fact,
I think you came from this organization and I'm going to let you go if you ever
want to come back here in earnest.
Do you know what?
I think you've got a lot of potential.
And I say,
I think,
hold on.
I think that the fact that they did this to you,
it shows that they don't really respect you.
Yeah.
And,
but if you want to come to a place where you will be respected and where we work
with integrity,
this is the place for you.
Let me know if that ever happens.
But for now,
because of the way this has shaken out,
I can't,
I can't have you here because you know what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to protect my team.
I'm trying to protect what we're doing here and you know we're doing,
we're doing something positive and your breath,
what you're bringing right now,
it shows you the weakness of the people that you've been working with on the
other side.
It shows you that they're weak,
they're trying to do these things.
It's not going to affect us by the way.
We are going to win.
Why are we going to win?
Because we are staying on the path.
See now you'll approach it like that.
You're going to win all day long.
So let's just retract.
You know?
That's why.
That's why people don't understand.
Man.
Integrity is so important and the minute you start giving up,
even under these adverse conditions,
when you give up your integrity in the long run,
you're going to hurt yourself.
And I kind of got drawn into it.
Right.
Even myself,
I'm like,
oh we spies and all this little be straight up.
Yeah.
Maintain your integrity.
Don't put them to death.
They're not allowed to do that.
Yeah.
Dang.
That's actually,
that's way more advanced than kind of what I was going to ask you.
So what if like
you expose them,
you know,
like you expose the company or the person like,
oh hey everyone,
I don't know.
You know,
not we have,
you know.
Yeah.
Well I think it'd be,
I would do it in an inappropriate way.
Yeah.
You know,
I wouldn't be trying to set them up and make 'em look up and say,
hey listen guys,
we found out that bill,
he's actually,
he's actually still getting paid by x company over there and bill,
we were going to have to let you go.
Appreciate you coming over.
But you know,
we,
here are a team,
we stick together.
You're not part of the team,
obviously,
so we can't have here.
If you ever decide that the weak team you came from is not for you and you want
to get on board with the winning team,
let me know.
Yeah,
that's advanced to kind of let them know that like,
Hey,
I still like you and everything kind of thing.
You know the opposite of burning a bridge.
Yeah.
It's like you're in a building and there is nothing better.
And a lot of times companies that we work with,
somebody will leave and it'll be under those weird circumstances.
Right?
They'll get a good offer,
you know,
and again,
all companies do this.
They say,
I'll give you a signing bonus,
signing bonus to come over.
Okay.
And a signing bonus.
That looks good.
That's a way to get somebody over.
And they say,
don't worry,
we'll give you this and we'll give you a corner office and we'll give you this.
We'll give you a helpers and we'll give you this title.
Right till they Lorman with all those things.
But all those are recruiters.
They're not telling the truth about stuff.
Sometimes I'm the worst.
The best recruiters tell everything straight up,
right?
The best recruiters are like,
oh,
you're doing this.
Yeah,
they were really good at that.
Your company,
you're at Echo,
they're really good with that.
You're right.
Here's where their weaknesses are.
Here's where we beat him.
Your decision,
it's,
it's honest and it's set your expectations,
right?
So when you show up,
you're not thinking,
well,
Joc,
what you said that this was the best at that x.
Now I didn't say that because they were the best of y in tax we're working on.
Right.
That's what you want to do.
It's just what I'm talking about is integrity.
That's what I'm talking about,
and you've got to maintain it.
Best thing to do.
Dang.
Easy to win in those scenarios,
is that one of those take the high road or then take the high,
take the high ground or the or the high ground is going to take you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
All right.
Back to the book.
If the soldiers show signs of cowardice,
various skills should be used to restore their courage.
Next.
Take your time and planning.
But when you have made decision,
be fast and putting it into action in war,
opportunity is fleeting
and cannot be put off at all.
Opportunity is fleeting and I was not just talking about war.
That's talking about business,
that's talking about life.
Your opportunities in life are fleeting.
What are you doing with them?
What are you doing with the opportunities you have in front of you right now?
Are you capitalizing on them?
Are you going after them?
Cause they're fleeting.
They're not going to be there.
They might be there tomorrow,
they might be in a week.
Where are they in a month?
Whether they're gone.
Opportunities are fleeting.
Get after them
next.
Let the army see that you are not unduly elated over successes nor utterly cast
down by failures.
We already covered that.
Next,
it is not the general whose words are frightening,
but the one who gets things done,
who is feared by the enemy.
That's a big one right there.
And be the person that makes things happen.
Yeah,
be the person that makes things happen.
That's it.
You,
you know,
in the military,
my guys,
I was at,
you know,
seal platoon or a seal task unit or when I was running training that I had guys,
my boys,
my people,
man,
they made things happen.
If I said something to him,
it was going to happen.
Who's going to happen?
There was no,
I didn't barely,
I can give them any direction as to,
hey,
we need this.
They take,
got it done.
Done.
Yeah.
That's the kind of person you want to be.
Not the person that comes back.
You know,
a week later we tried to make some progress here,
but I really run into a brick wall with so and so.
Oh yeah.
My guys didn't hit brick walls and if they hit him,
they hit him with sledge hammers and busted through him.
So geed would
j Charles Echo Charles's brother.
Yup.
So He'd be like,
yeah,
this happened more than once.
Is YMC saying he would do this,
but I'll maybe twice.
I don't know anyone.
He'd say,
Hey,
I know you're going in the store,
go buy me some wine while you're there.
And he's like,
hey,
it's this kind of whatever kind point.
So I'm like,
all right,
I'll do that for you.
You know,
favor kind,
no problem.
I go in the wine section aisle,
whatever.
And he's like,
hey,
it's this.
And if there's,
you know,
there's white,
there's White Ryan read rang Bordeaux,
Cabernet Ball.
This one.
Yeah.
And then there's the brand.
So basically it's a wall.
The whole thing is all wines.
It's not the kind of resist sugar oil,
this all wine,
different kinds.
And he's like,
I want this guy and I'm looking at this thing.
Browse here for tomatoes.
That's it.
I don't want to spend one hour looking for way.
So you kind of come to like this decision you gotta make,
you know,
I could easily just grab my tomatoes,
go home and be like,
Bruh,
you know what you sent?
You sent me on a treasure hunt for year one.
I could say that and it'd be justifiable.
Really.
So I'll have a bottle.
No,
yeah,
no.
As you'd say,
he hold the line.
He asked for wine.
I said I would get wine,
I'm going to get wine.
And I'm not gonna say anything about it.
That's what I did.
Found it.
Give it to him and I know where it is now.
Legit.
Right.
Cause justifiably I could've said,
hey,
I'll do it next time or show next time we're there.
Show me where it is.
You know,
but,
but I didn't have that kind of time.
Whatever,
you know you got the mission done.
Yeah.
Do uh,
wha wha what did the guys say?
They say don't talk about it.
Be about it.
Don't talk about it.
All right.
Next.
Plan what you have to do at night and carry out your decision during the day.
One cannot plan an act at the same time
for you to bed at night.
Make your list of what God's to get done
next.
The general who is overly harsh with his subordinates and the one who is too
indulgent are both on fit for command.
Yeah.
Fear leads to great hatred and giving in too much results in being despised.
Okay.
It is best to take the middle course
means balance.
You gotta balance.
So this is the dichotomy of leadership.
Nope.
Don't be overly harsh.
Don't want to be too indulgent.
I liked the fact that he says giving too much results in being despised.
Yeah,
and it's interesting you got,
I got,
I hear,
I've heard that like in the seal teams,
if you heard that expression.
No,
I haven't seen that idea where you get a guy,
of course you get a guy,
you get a platoon leader that's really over the bearing and and no one likes
him.
Yeah.
And it's not a good unit,
but you get the guy that just gives everything he's not liked either.
They need not respected.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
And he might be able to,
his body doesn't make anything happen.
It doesn't have a good unit.
Maybe not enough.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
Next,
after agreeing upon a treaty or a truce with the enemy,
the commander should make sure that as camp is guarded more strongly and more
closely,
I bet you Marise the way he writes these things,
they must have gotten re attacked on multiple occasions because he is paranoid.
If the enemy chooses to break the agreement,
they will only gain a reputation for faithlessness.
And Disfavor of God.
While we shall remain in safety and be true to our word,
a general should not have to say,
I did not expect it.
Next,
for smaller forces,
we should select a place with a narrow who's with corresponds to the size of our
army.
The superior numbers of the enemy are useless in such a place since there is no
room for them.
This is classic bottle.
Have battled for knobbly.
Pick a place that's really narrow so all those Persians can't attack you at the
same time.
Is it a good idea to maneuver so that the sun,
wind,
and dust are behind our men and in the face of the enemy?
By so obscuring his vision and making his breathing difficult,
we should quickly be victorious.
Think about those environmentals.
Yeah.
Next we should put,
we should line up our troops for battle before the enemy gets ready.
This puts us in a position to do what we wish and barely allows the enemy time
to arm.
So be ahead.
Be early,
get up early,
be first,
be first.
Okay.
If we are all set for the charge,
then we can attack the enemy in safety with our men.
Full of confidence in the enemy.
Very worried.
Next,
if the enemy has put to flight,
our soldiers must be restrained from plundering.
Otherwise they are scattered doing.
While they are scattered doing this,
the enemy might reform and attack them.
Once again,
I like Maria's paranoia.
Hmm.
Next,
the general is at fault.
If most of the army is destroyed in a single battle.
We wrote a book called extreme ownership.
That's what it's about.
Own it.
Next and army,
which shouts out its war cries good and loud,
can strike terror into the enemy.
Is that like the rugby,
the New Zealand,
the hotdog,
blacks,
you know they're,
yeah,
they're doing that.
Yeah.
Aw.
Cause awesome.
Have you ever seen there's a,
there's a,
they do the Haka and like memorial services.
Yeah.
That is,
that is very moving and it doesn't give much more movies that
yeah,
they,
they get up.
Even the football teams in Hawaii do that too.
So some of them,
they'll do that before the game.
It's kind of,
I think in Hawaii they're youth kind of used to it.
So this might not have the effect,
but what if like you never seen him before,
you're not expecting and they do that.
You're like,
Bro,
these guys are kind of like,
they're ready.
They're nuts,
you know?
Yeah.
That's cool.
Next,
our commander all to adapt his strategy rims to the disposition of the enemy
general.
If the ladder is inclined to rash nish he might be enticed to premature and
reckless action.
If he is on the timid side,
he may be struck down by continual surprise rates or you're making adaptions,
they're like,
oh,
I know you've got a bad temper.
Oh,
I'm going to be able to bring it out.
Or you're,
you're passive.
Cool.
I'm gonna get aggressive on you.
The general should be,
and dealing with zone
man,
with allied and with allied forces,
he should be adjust judged for both.
When he gives presence to the allies,
he should make a regular increase in the gratuities for his own soldiers.
So he's talking about they would adopt these other armies and he seen treat them
fairly.
Treat them.
Just so you know,
where you see this as a lot is when,
uh,
when we get acquisitions in the business world,
so one company takes over another company and a good leader is going to treat
people fairly.
A bad leader is going to be taken care of the guys that he's always been with
his boys.
Yep.
So you gotta be careful of that.
Yeah.
In wartime,
the general should do more than his share of the work and take less than his
share of the gain.
This will enhance his reputation and secure for him the goodwill of all do more
than your share of work and take less of the share of the gain.
Aware of the uncertainties of board.
The general ought to be ready even after victory to listen to the proposals of
the enemy for peace on advantageous terms.
So got to keep an open mind.
The best general was not the man of noble family,
but the man who can take pride in his own deeds.
Next,
the general must correctly manage not only matters of immediate concern,
but most also take thought for the future.
Common Sense.
But how often do we see people not doing that?
Not Thinking about the future only mean concerned with what's happening right
now.
Hmm.
Next,
the best leader is one who does not willingly engage in a hazardous and highly
uncertain battle and refrains from emulating those who carry out operations
recklessly and are admired for their brilliant success,
but one who,
while keeping the enemy on the move,
remain secure and always in circumstances of his own choosing.
We dictate the situation.
A greedy general can be the ruin of his own people and an object of contempt to
the enemy.
A general COO loves luxury can destroy the whole army.
Okay,
next,
the commander is the one who can instill courage at the right time and can hold
back the head.
Long flight of frightened soldiers.
Next,
a general who desires piece must be prepared for war for the barbarians.
Become very nervous when they face an adversary.
All set to fight.
Okay.
That is why my,
that is why my foreign policy is one word strength,
because the barbarians getting nervous when they know you're ready to fight.
Yeah.
Mistakes made in ordinary affairs can generally be remedied in a short while,
but errors made in war cause lasting harm.
This is why this is why combat is like life,
but amplified and intensified.
Next.
Those whose performance is consistently poor should not be in trusted,
even with just ordinary responsibilities.
Next,
the general,
the sharp a general takes into account not only probable dangers,
but also those which may be totally unexpected.
Next,
make peace.
A time of training for war and battle,
an exhibition of bravery.
So during peace,
prepare.
Hmm.
Next,
the general should not go to sleep before reflecting on what he should have done
that he might've neglected and on what he has to do the next day.
Get ready for the next day,
the night before period.
Can you do that?
Yes.
You can think that's good to do.
Not good bed without reflecting on it.
I think I don't.
It seems like that's something that that most people probably wouldn't do it
just in life.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
This is about life.
You don't have to put that caveat on there.
This is about life,
life thing.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
I mean shoot,
go to bed.
It's time to go to bed.
Yeah,
whatever.
I got work tomorrow,
but you know,
you typically,
you don't run it.
That doesn't take long to say,
you know what,
this is what I got done today.
Yeah.
This is what I got done today.
And you know what?
This is something to think about when it's,
when you're prepping to get stuff done.
When you know you've got a long day,
think about how good it feels when you accomplish a lot in one day.
That's how you want to go to bed at night.
You know,
going,
yeah,
I nailed this.
Oh,
I messed up this,
but I'm going to get on it tomorrow and fix it.
Yeah,
that's the part,
right?
[inaudible] doesn't take long.
Let me do that.
Echo is going to do it.
And why don't you do it while you're editing videos for this podcast?
I do brand.
I like it.
Next it is well for the general to exercise self control at all times,
but especially during war.
Yeah.
Next,
the general should not be hasty in placing confidence in people who promised to
do something.
If he does,
almost everyone will think he's light headed.
So you gotta,
you can't just be a you.
I know you're going to take care of it.
I trust you kind of got to put it in check a little bit.
Next long.
And careful deliberation promises great safety in war,
whereas hasty an impetuous generals usually commit serious blunders.
Next,
the general should set an example of how things ought to be done for his
subordinates.
Training himself in the highest ideals,
doing what is right and refraining from those things his soldiers should refrain
from.
Set the example.
Mm.
The general should make sure of the good disposition of his troops by an oath.
Next,
if the general knows the inclinations and tendencies of each officer and
soldier,
he will know better what duties should be assigned to each one.
Know your people.
Next,
the general who wants to keep his plans concealed from the enemy should never
take the rank and file of his own troops into his confidence.
So just be careful.
Be careful who you're telling
and does that,
does that contradict,
you know,
having a well does that transparent transparency in your leadership?
No,
it doesn't.
You,
you,
you don't have to divulge every single idea that you have to your entire chain
of command,
especially because you're going to change those ideas.
Things are going to adapt.
Things are gonna get different.
So this isn't contradictory to say,
you know what,
I'm not going to tell every single person,
especially if you've got a security situation,
right?
I mean,
we're talking about national security.
Yeah.
There's things that are need to know only that's a legitimate thing.
In fact,
it doesn't need to know this.
And that can happen in the business world too,
because you do have people leaving.
You do have spies.
You do have all these people coming and going from businesses.
So this is legit.
This isn't,
this isn't a lack of transparency.
This is prudent.
Yeah.
Information control.
I go home,
I tell my wife,
and she's cruising with her neighbor and they're like,
hey,
that was interesting.
So the wife goes home,
tells the husband,
and I was putting that into who's putting together all those little dots?
A picture
next.
When both sides are equally well armed,
the better tactician will win.
Yeah.
Next,
the gentleman who possesses some skill in public speaking is able as in the
past,
to rouse the weak hearted to battle and restore courage to a defeated army.
Work on skills.
Just like
we learned in the,
in the guidebook,
the 1950 guidebook for military officers work on your speaking skills.
How do you do at practice?
Hmm.
It is good to occupy any hills in the area before the enemy has a chance to do
so.
Boom,
take the high ground.
Nope.
This is awesome.
Reiterated again and again and again.
Take the high ground.
Next as in the past,
misleading moves taken by the general can be very advantageous.
For example,
if he makes it look as though he's going to set up camp,
the enemy might be lowered into doing the same thing.
Then while they are scattered about getting things ready,
he may secretly drop his troops in attack where you may quietly withdraw his
army.
If the terrain is unfavorable,
simple.
Next in his movements,
the general should act like a good wrestler.
He should faint in one direction to try and deceive his adversary and then make
good use of the opportunities he fines and in this way he will overpower the
enemy.
Same thing that you do too,
by the way.
Ready could swap those out.
I guess he could have said Ping Christian.
Sure.
Next in battles and in every action against the enemy,
the wise general,
even the most courageous.
We'll keep in mind the possibility of failure and defeat and we'll plan for them
has actually occurring.
Yeah.
Huh?
You're confident.
That's great.
Plan of what's gonna happen if it fails,
what's the worst case scenario?
What if things go wrong?
What are you going to do?
Hmm.
The spirit of the commander is naturally communicated to the troops and there
was an ancient saying that is better to have an army of deer commanded by a lion
than an army of lions commanded by a deer.
Yeah,
that's a pretty common one.
Next,
if you imitate the enemy and do what he is doing for his own benefit,
you only harm yourself.
Conversely,
if you do something which is to your advantage in trying to imitate you,
the enemy will injure himself.
A lot of times you do see that in the business world where the competitor is
something,
so that all will do it too.
Yeah.
I'm not saying that never good,
but if you're doing that means you're behind.
Hmm.
So try and step up,
come with some original plans and make something happen.
Next,
a wise commander will not engage the enemy in a pitched battle unless truly
exceptional opportunity or advantage is present and vantage presents itself.
We're hearing that over and over again.
Next,
whatever terrain the general chooses,
he should make his troops familiar with it.
They will then be able to avoid rough spots and because of their knowledge of
the area will fight the enemy with confidence.
Know your terrain.
Next.
When the general leads his men out to battle,
he should present a cheerful of appearance,
avoiding any gloomy look.
Soldiers usually estimate their prospects by the appearance of the general,
so if you're in a leadership position,
that's what they're saying.
If you're in a leadership position that people are watching you and if you look
like Sullen and downtrodden,
guess what?
They're going to think we're good about to get warped
next.
After a victory,
the general should not allow the men to break ranks right away for his happened.
Often enough that the enemy on noticing that our men have let down their guard
and rejoicing and if broken ranks have regained their courage,
come back to fight and turned our victory into defeat.
Don't let your guard down.
Boom.
I think we're hearing that loud and clear from a Reese next when the enemy's
surrounded as well to leave a gap in our lines to give them an opportunity to
flee in case they judged that flight is better than remaining and taking their
chances in battle.
Next in army is judged by the spirit of it's general.
Next,
it is better to avoid a tricky opponent than one who never lets up.
Let me say that again.
It's better to avoid a tricky opponent than one who never lets up the ladder,
makes no secret of what he's doing.
Whereas it is difficult to find what the other is up to.
So conversely,
which one do you want to be?
Of course we want to have determination and we never want one of them.
Make sure they know that we're never going to let up,
but you really want to be the one that keeps them guessing.
Yeah,
harder to deal with.
Next,
the commanders should be severe and thorough and investigating charges against
his men,
but merciful in punishing them.
This will gain him in their goodwill,
in their goodwill.
Next,
the general should be common emergencies,
prudent in council,
courteous to his associates.
He will be most successful in battle if he charges against the enemy.
Not like a wild beast,
but in a calculated manner.
Okay.
Next,
the general should be ignorant of none of the situations likely to occur in war.
Who can attempt to accomplish what he does not understand and ask that again.
Who can attempt to accomplish what he does not understand?
Who is able to furnish assistance and situation,
who's dangerous?
He does not understand.
So you got to get the knowledge.
Next,
the general must make plans to defeat the enemy,
not only by arms,
but also through their food and drink,
making the water unfit to drink and poisoning the grain.
And that's again,
we're not just attacking on one front,
we're tacking on all the fronts.
We're not just attacking with swords and bows and arrows and Lance's were
poisoning the water for poisoning the grain.
We're attacking it every possible angle.
And that wraps it up.
That's,
that's Maurice's
strategic con.
And by the way,
I forgot to mention this.
This is somebody,
somebody on Twitter said,
hey,
check out this book.
I got it,
opened it up and said,
yes,
ancient war.
Bring it maxims,
bring it.
Awesome book.
And you know,
I wanted to close this out kind of with something
Roman related.
And of course I thought about Julius.
And when you think of Rome,
you think of Julius Caesar.
When you think of Julius Caesar,
you think about that guy named Shakespeare.
Sure.
Who wrote a play called Julius Caesar and obviously not going to do the whole
thing right now,
but there's a
part of it.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
we're,
we're talking about leadership,
right?
And really in,
in talking about Maurice and Caesar actual rulers of an empire,
that's what they were rulers of an empire.
It,
it's possible to think that maybe they were better than us,
right?
Like they were superior human beings.
Yeah.
And
it's also possible to think that they were better than us,
not by what they did and how they led.
It's possible to say,
Oh,
you know,
Maurice came up with this stuff.
Nah,
that's just,
that's not why he was the ruler.
This is luck fate.
But in the play,
Julius Caesar by Shakespeare Cassius reminds us as he speaks to Brutus that that
isn't so not so not luck.
He explains to Caesar in these great lines,
he explained to him that that the Caesar stands above the world like a giant.
So Caesar's a giant like a colossus is the word he uses while we us down here,
we little men,
we just wander about,
wander about under his massive legs,
under his giant presence.
We're just where does moving aimlessly towards a,
toward death,
towards a dishonorable death.
But this is what I like about is then Cassius explains that it isn't fate
that is put Cesar into that powerful position,
but that men,
men control their own destinies
and that men are masters of their fate
and that the fault in men,
the thing that holds us back from greatness,
it doesn't lie in chance.
It doesn't lie in the way that the stars are aligned.
No,
the fault lies within us,
not in the stars.
It is our fault
that we become slaves instead of kings.
Okay.
And this is,
this is how Shakespeare put it.
Why man,
he doff the stride,
the narrow world like a colossus
and we petty men walk under his huge legs in peep about to find ourselves.
Dishonorable graves.
Men at some time are masters of their fate.
The fault,
dear Brutus is not in our stars,
but in our selves
that we
are underlings.
So Cassie is there,
is making an early case for ownership for extreme ownership,
which is obviously something that I believe in.
Yeah.
Then that is that you can't blame fee.
You can't blame the stars.
The fault lies within us and you've got to own it.
You got to own that fault.
You got to fix it.
You got to dictate your own future.
Don't let fate dictate your future
you.
You got
to make that decision to be better,
to be a king like Caesar,
to be a general,
to be a leader and most most important
to be a free human beings.
What he's talking about,
he's talking about underlings,
their slaves.
Don't be a slave.
Be a sleeve to any other man and don't be a slave to weakness and don't be a
slave to slow off.
I don't be a slave to your ego.
Don't be a slave,
be free,
free your mind.
And the thing is you can't free your mind until you realize.
Like Cassius says,
the fault is in ourselves and the pathway to overcoming our fault is not
complaining or blaming or making excuses
or attacking others.
No.
The pathway to freedom actually comes from attacking ourselves,
attacking ourselves with with discipline and with hard work,
pain with physical training and mental training in reading and studying and
learning.
Then that,
that is how
we overcome those faults.
That's how we leave behind the underlings,
the slaves.
That's how we get away from the darkness of subjugation
and that is how
we become free.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
Looks like we're pretty long to slide into Q and a right now.
Yep.
So
Echo.
Yes sir.
If we are not going to do Q and a,
I have a question.
Hit me if people we wanted to support this podcast.
Sure.
Do you know of any ways that they can do that?
I do.
As a matter of fact,
let me go.
Let me tell you about it.
So people have been asking me and not the kind
of,
you know how like some people they'll,
they'll say that they'll be like,
hey people,
a lot of people have been asking me about this,
but it's like two people and they see a lot of people.
It's not that case.
There's a lot of people probably like 20 people,
which is a lot of people asking the same question by the way.
So anyway,
yeah,
they're like,
hey,
what,
what supplements?
Or are these Onnit Kim on amp talking about on it?
So the supplements and the Krill oil is that the good stuff is the strewn tech,
is that the good stuff?
And I was like,
cool.
Um,
yeah,
they're,
they're the good stuff or whatever.
But so kind of thinking,
I was thinking about this one us actually working out and I was like,
hey to myself,
it's not like the supplements you take aren't gonna like get you in Jocko shape,
you know,
it's going to be like all the other stuff.
Like,
do you mean hard work?
Yes,
exactly.
You know,
we'll work out diet,
rest,
like all this stuff.
And if you have like,
you know,
whatever goal
the supplements are gonna like they're gonna help you get there faster,
they're going to create less roadblocks that,
you know,
injuries,
all this other stuff,
keep you put you and or keep you in better health.
Like all this stuff.
Right.
But the way I kind of,
I don't know,
I could have been taken her wrong though,
that it sounded like they were like,
oh yeah,
I'm looking for like the answer kind of thing.
Not all of them,
but that's kind of,
I don't know,
maybe it was just collectively that's what it felt like.
Yeah.
So I think that's important to point out on this or not.
Those supplements are not the answer.
Yeah.
Your squat rack is dancing.
Your pull up bars.
The answer.
Yeah.
And you've got to do that stuff over and over and over.
Like,
you know how,
okay,
I'm not gonna mention his name,
but one of my friends would be like,
yeah,
you're like,
you're a genetic guy.
Whatever.
You know,
they'll be like,
yeah,
Janette,
your genetics are like good.
And I'm not saying my genetics are not good.
I'm not gonna say they are or are not.
I'm not saying that.
But I got into like working out when I was 14 years old.
Did it stop by the way,
knew about like diet and all this other stuff.
So when you hit,
let's say,
let's say you had not started working out when you're 14 let's say you were
like,
Oh,
you know,
I,
I know what a weight room is kind of thing.
I'm out of shape.
I'm 35 or whatever,
however old,
and you say,
I want to get in good shape.
It's like that's a completely different situation,
you know?
Yeah.
You could possibly try and blame the fault on your genetics,
but it's not the fault of your exact to the stars maybe exalted as yours yet.
So she didn't work out.
Now you could say,
Hey,
I didn't,
wasn't a environment.
Okay,
cool.
That doesn't matter anymore.
Right.
What matters is how you're going to fix it.
Yeah.
What are we going to do?
Exactly.
Right.
So,
which brings us to the same kind of,
this profile may be fundamental concept of,
it's not like it's not these external things.
You're not going to escape fact that if you want like get in shape,
you gotta go get in shape.
And that entails these fundamental things.
It's not going to be the supplements,
it's not going to be your genetics,
the supplements,
genetics,
all this stuff.
That's part of the game for sure.
But that's not what's gonna get you there.
So that being said,
I'm going to recommend some supplements,
but in the hopes of us,
everybody being on a good workup program,
yes,
these will help you if you're on a good workout program.
By the way,
these will definitely help you and a lot of people,
speaking of,
again,
a lot of people,
I don't mean to,
yeah,
I mean more than to
think about all the people on Twitter that have said,
oh,
I've been taking krill oil.
Yes,
my knees feel better now.
All my shoulders feel better.
No,
that's,
that's a fact.
Krill Krill oil works.
Yeah.
And personally,
however many people told me that it worked for them,
that has no bearing on my understanding that it works because it works for me
and I don't take like protein massive gainer to get big.
I don't do that.
You can I guess.
And that's cool.
And I'm not gonna recommend necessarily that,
but like Krill oil for example,
like that,
we'll keep you in the game way more in my opinion.
Then it will like a creatine situation I think.
And again,
I agree with you and your,
by the way,
for those who don't know,
echo does have a doctorate and bro Science.
Yes.
Well if you notice,
I won't make any scientifically lanes.
Yes.
Or maybe I will.
I don't know.
Well the,
the best claim you can make is that you use it and you feel it.
That's,
yeah.
You know that is bro Science,
I guess.
Yes.
Well it's anecdotal to 10 but what if it works for me too?
Yeah.
There you go to two people.
Then we're starting to paint that picture with the dots.
Remember who you're talking about her the same thing.
And,
and I do want to add that that does mean something when I say it works for me
because I was for a long time time anti slip supplements where it's like,
yeah,
you're just taking that to make yourself feel better about working out or
whatever.
And they're selling it to you because they're telling you the same thing for
long time and take any supplements and still had gains and all,
you know,
who's doing fine big time.
Um,
so I was like,
yeah,
supplements.
You know when people talk about supplements so they bro,
you're totally wasting your time because you can just eat good and eat enough of
the right thing and,
and do everything that you can do that.
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
I don't know if you can do that with Krill oil unless you're eating a bunch of
Krill in a smoothie or something.
Even that,
I don't know,
you know,
do Kenyon shroom tech,
how can you replace that with diet?
I don't know if you can man.
So I'm slowly,
and this is what it was.
He was like the correct 10 supplements.
That's what it is.
So krill oil,
take care of your joints.
The other ones that you shaved your,
the bones strong and bone.
Yeah.
Dope.
I'm shroom tech.
If you want a little boo efficient oxygen usage,
you know,
keep you in that,
those hard workouts longer,
better,
more comfortable.
Get you in the like in the car,
the Rpms,
you know what goes,
it's in the black and then it goes into,
we know,
we know because they told you,
you told us.
Tell us what the slogan is.
You can't pull ahead if you're in the red.
So the shroom tech keeps you in that like the yellow,
maybe the orange.
Anyway,
the other day shroom tech I took,
we showed up to train and it was the kind of the,
the pipe hitting training partners.
You know the guys that,
the big dogs.
Yeah,
And before I waited,
before I went,
I had worked out as normal.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
But I took,
not only did I take shroom tech sport,
I also took the pre workout drink.
Yeah.
What is it called?
Earth grown earthbound something.
It's pre workout.
And I took both and we did 10 rounds,
you know,
10 rounds.
That's a little ten five minutes early.
They were firing rounds because I was trained MMA fighters.
So,
but it's hand one hour a little over an hour of training.
I was good.
You showed await.
Okay.
For that one.
Yeah.
But,
but I walked out of there going hmm.
Tags Room today.
Yes.
10 rounds is hardcore when you're going with no cause cause you can do around
with three hard guys and then you go against someone that's not that great and
you can completely relax and recover some activity coloring.
You are going against.
Every guy is trying to rip your head off and they have the capability of unit 10
rounds.
A lot of rounds know tech and the feeling there is,
cause I've been in the same boat.
Uh,
I'm not going to necessarily say 10 rounds but in the same boat where a lot of
rounds reco actually I've done six tens breast takes 10 minutes.
It might be harder.
Yeah.
Some might consider with heavy hitters.
Have you?
Yeah.
That's tiring.
Yes.
So basically what the shroom tech will do is put in layman's term.
What it will do is you know the field,
let's say you go six tenths,
who actually can you do scientific terms for us here?
Not at all.
I'm going to laymen
after the sixth 10th or the one hour of rolling,
you're going to be like Phil.
Just physically,
you know like Dang,
I'm done.
That felt good,
whatever,
but we're done.
I'm good.
I'm going to go home and arrest,
eat my stuff.
I'm good.
Yeah.
And even today when I showed up today to roll and we had some,
we didn't do anything that extreme,
but when I showed up I already worked out hard strength and metcon.
Then I went surfing,
you know,
gave them after it.
Sure.
Shredding Dee Dee didn't eat anything but just rolled in.
I had some,
I take that back.
I had some bacon,
like three pieces of bacon in between working out and so I was like,
I had some bacon.
Sure.
Good Shit.
Then I had some shroom tech.
I just rubbed it on the way to the gym.
I drank the a the pre workout stuff.
Yeah.
And I felt ready to rock and roll.
Well I'm actually,
instead of me saying I was ready to rock and roll,
why don't you answer that question.
Jocko appeared and demonstrated that he was ready to rock and roll as it were.
I actually wasn't read to actually did rock and roll,
which is,
which is great.
You were,
you were,
you didn't talk about it.
You beat about it.
Yeah,
that'd be about it afterwards.
After the hard rules with the shroom tech,
you'll feel like.
Sure.
Yeah.
That was good.
That was hard.
I could go another one like I could keep going.
Just how you feel.
Not necessarily that you want to keep going,
but you could,
you feel like you could,
I mean I want it where we will the podcast.
Yeah.
So that's a different button.
I get it anyway.
Yeah,
it's true.
And Tech,
that's a good on shroom tech sport still haven't,
didn't done from tech immune.
I think that's the next one.
Yeah.
Where are your bars and,
okay,
so we'll talk about that.
Preworkout one and I only,
I took it one time for rolling and I was like,
okay,
cool.
But I'd been taking it all week for lifting,
working out,
met cons.
Very,
very good.
Very effective.
Okay.
And here's,
here's the,
the,
the relief,
the results,
the proof straight up.
He's right.
So you know how like,
okay,
do you do,
do you do any kind of like pressing or any kind of lifting,
doing pull ups or something?
You know how some days you're like,
oh,
I feel like flat,
I can still do them,
but I feel flat.
Then some days is opposite where you're like,
oh my God,
a little pot in my thing.
Not necessarily stronger or doing more.
Maybe you are,
but I just got a little pop in it,
in my movement or whatever.
That's how you film.
And it was noticeable and I was like,
okay.
And here's the thing with mine,
I did do more,
more weight than I normally do,
more reps than I normally do.
But I was like,
okay,
those are the first sales.
Like,
okay.
You know,
that easily could have been other circumstances.
Totally could.
Yeah.
Cause sometimes you just feel them pop,
feel the pot,
you've got more rest.
You know,
yesterday was easier.
I don't know,
whatever,
all these other circumstances,
you never know.
So boom,
next time I lift do it again.
St Pop,
same feeling.
I was like,
okay.
And that's different.
Typically you don't get two pups in it in a week.
So anyway,
next time I go I go in again.
I'm like,
all right,
we're going to keep,
this coin is the telltale.
So here's what happens.
So I warm up,
my routine is a warmup.
I work out,
that's it.
I warm up and I had my son and he needs some something.
Without going too far into it,
I warm up,
ready to go,
ready to go first set,
he needs something for half an hour.
I'm like,
okay,
you know,
I go,
so do I have to warm up again?
Am I,
you know,
am I going to utilize the pop to care for your son?
So no,
no.
What I'm saying is kind of physiologically and mentally it I'm out of.
I went out of the game for a little bit out of the workout,
so I come back,
I got to reengage mentally and I'm fit to be honest,
like mental health,
shoot them kind of flap back in the day.
That might've posable Norco till tomorrow,
back in the day anyway,
so I'm like,
all right,
I'm a little bit flat,
whatever.
I truly,
I'm working out today.
That's it.
You know,
whatever.
Oh,
maybe you've got a warm up again.
I don't know.
Maybe you just got to get mentally harder for sure.
Yeah,
that's no question about that.
Everyone knows that,
so whatever I get under there,
I choose the weight that I had already showed,
you know,
chose before when I was like,
I'm,
I'm in it.
Yeah,
boom,
boom.
More reps than I expected.
It was a winning day.
That's good.
Three in a row.
Anyway,
that was it sounding like some strong,
well,
I'm in,
it's,
to me that's like,
okay.
Even if you say scientific proof or not scientific role,
of course in that scientific proof,
but that's like,
to me that says,
okay,
this is something you're going to be taken now.
You know what I mean?
It's not like I tried at me no different.
I'll try it again.
Maybe a different sort of what the 10 rounds give me.
Yeah,
you're on your,
you're in it.
You know what I did today?
Target again,
do it again.
There you go.
You know,
and actually we had some no shows today at the gym.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I wasn't one of those.
So yeah,
you were there.
I was there,
but,
and we had some other heavy hitters there,
but we didn't get the full spectrum spectrum of heavy hitters that were there to
crush.
So I didn't even need to take it.
Yeah,
it didn't get put to the test.
No,
it's good.
So now I'm kind of,
in a way,
I'm my supplement guy.
Okay.
So if people wanted to get these supplements,
how could they get them
on it.com you want 10% off?
You go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko you want the 10% off and support
yourself,
support the podcast if you're in the mood to and you know,
go handle your business.
Another cool way Amazon click through.
So
Sarah,
thanks for the duct tape.
I want to say that all the d the duct to have like a pilot duck tape too,
which is none of it here by the way.
No,
because I needed it.
She sent it to her phones.
Yeah,
well there's smiley faces on it.
It can't be on the podcast,
but this smiley face.
So you know,
now the new iPhones,
you type a word and it,
it suggests Emoji.
If you type in good,
guess what's right there.
That's my face.
Should be your face.
But now it's a smiley face.
Currently slack HQ has,
that's for some reason.
Yeah,
I face or someone,
I don't really understand it fully,
but somebody sent me a little picture of an Emoji that said good.
Yeah.
So it's kind of the same concept,
but generally speaking,
it's a smiley face.
Smiley face went on the duct tape layers is insane.
And the ones that's good.
Good duct tape.
But emoji style,
you know Sarah is,
she's clever like that.
Anyway,
the point is Amazon,
if you're shopping for duct tape or anything else,
not necessarily duct tape,
but I'm like books,
you know,
you want to get this one or,
and we list that on the website too.
By the way,
if you didn't already know,
um,
click through,
go to the website Jocko,
podcast.com.
Click through the Amazon banner over there on the site and then do your
shopping.
Can support by cast that way.
You said small click like it takes like two seconds,
right?
Click on it.
Go do your shopping,
two seconds supports,
you know,
like a big amount.
Well because there's a lot more than just you.
Yeah.
Cause I like just one.
It's not just one person clicking.
Yeah.
Which would be helpful.
But when a bunch of people click through is very helpful.
Yeah.
Creates a bigger reaction.
So small action.
Huge reaction.
And I made the reference to when you throw a small piece of sodium metal in a,
you know,
in water and the big chemical reaction,
something like,
wait,
did I remember that correctly?
I looked up on youtube,
look up.
So put sodium in water,
it looked that up.
So you get guys,
they'll,
they'll have a big fish tank with water.
They'll throw the sodium and the fish tank will blow up.
People posted them on Twitter.
Did you do the one where somebody had a,
somebody is holding a small brick of sodium food in lake.
Did you [inaudible]
I'll leave her ass.
So seniors get that exactly.
Wrestle when you,
next time you shop Amazon,
you think,
Hey,
I'm shopping Amazon.
I'm going to buy some batteries.
That little click through the Jocko podcast.com boom.
That's that sodium that we were looking at on those videos.
It's crazy.
Anyway,
that's a good way to support in a big way.
Uh,
and and uh,
yes.
Uh,
youtube,
that's a good one,
right?
Subscribe to the Youtube Channel.
Subscribe to the iTunes one as well.
But that one seems kind of obvious.
Most people are already subscribed,
but if you haven't,
well we went over,
we went over an entire book today of obvious things that people don't always
don't myself,
so we need to reiterate just so we all make sure we're on board.
Yeah.
Reinforced with our friends.
Yes.
You should always be prepared.
Always what I've heard.
Yeah.
Really that one was all about preparedness.
Subscribe,
iTunes,
subscribe.
Be a subscriber to the podcast and that's no commitment.
You just unsubscribe.
If you don't like what Jack was talking about,
you just subscribe.
But if you like and you do want to support [inaudible] you're talking about that
too.
You know that too.
I heard some rumor that he's a popper.
Youtube.
Luckily you don't talk a lot.
Yeah.
I try to keep it to like sometimes you can just suck it up,
you know,
want the fast forward his voice.
Yeah.
And most of you don't realize that you're pretty screwed.
You can have a long,
long struggle or just people that are there just listening to echo their like
fast forwarding through me.
Yeah.
You press the skips,
Gay San second goes about to say something super dope.
The one guy,
my mom or something like this.
Anyway,
youtube,
we do more videos now.
We pulled out the little,
the shareable nuggets,
bread,
how's this?
My brother the other day,
he's like,
hey,
there's this new guy,
you know,
he listens to a lot of like talks and stuff.
They said,
you guys talking about this?
I'm like,
oh,
that's good.
He's like,
Hey,
he's talking about he into this little ideas that he's talking.
I was like,
oh.
Hey,
send that to me and I usually won't tell.
I'll be like,
cool,
maybe I'll look into it kind of thing.
And I'm like,
does this one sound good?
I said,
send it to me,
send it to its hour,
37 minutes long.
I'm like,
Bro.
Yeah,
I,
and I scolded him.
I said,
Bro,
you can't do that to me.
We've got him two likes on the thing.
You're going to have everyone that listens,
scolding you.
Yeah,
but not anymore.
You know why?
Because we have chocolate mcnuggets three minutes.
You want to learn about how to,
how to not learn necessarily,
but yeah,
if you want advice,
good advice,
Jocko,
advice on what,
how you should approach college after the military,
after high school,
whatever.
Go ahead and listen to that three,
four minutes.
Boom,
you're good to go.
You're ready to go to college.
Created a function.
If you say,
hey,
listen to this podcast,
it's in there somewhere,
two hours long.
No.
Anyway,
I don't,
people don't have the attention span for that.
But you do other ones besides just college.
Exactly right.
We do multiple [inaudible] McMahon.
I do suggestions like got 20 pack of mcnuggets.
Sure.
More than that even really and you know,
you can share and consume,
you know,
boom,
boom.
I do suggestions as well.
Requests,
if you will.
People on Twitter,
they're like,
Hey Jocko podcast,
what does it take to actually make that come true?
It's not a 100% turnover.
People don't like that.
I know and liable.
It's quite respond and say yes or no
kind of.
Yeah.
I don't say yes or no.
Like yes,
I'm going to do that one.
I'm,
I just noted,
you know,
so,
yeah.
I mean they're all go did I know?
But when they see them,
boom,
there it is.
You should actually tell him that.
I know.
Might be hard maybe because you're going to lose track of them all.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Or maybe you should just do them all.
Oh yeah,
there it is.
I think that sense.
But yeah,
so you know,
there's no downside,
right?
There's no downside to doing them all,
dude.
No.
To doing a book.
There's,
is there a downside to saying making a bunch of them,
there's not,
unless you make ones that are lame,
right.
Unless you pick out a lame one.
When I'm talking about something stupid or making mistakes or giving bad advice
to the world,
don't do those.
Those are the,
that's the downside for sure.
Good ones.
Yeah,
no downside.
Okay.
There you go.
And when you subscribe,
boom,
you,
you have like,
cause they notified because I subscribed.
Yeah.
And when you upload something,
you don't tell me.
Right.
I just get a leave mail that says Jocko podcast just uploaded a video and I was
going,
wow.
Yes.
Yeah.
Echo has been hard at work for four minutes to making a video
anyway.
It's good to um,
or taking heavies today for me.
I'm,
I'm sorry.
All Day April.
All good though.
I did get off of brainstorms all,
I don't think.
Yeah,
so some credit t subscribe if you're in the mood,
subscribe to youtube if you like that stuff,
which is cool.
Um,
and then of course Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store.
Url Is Jocko store.com.
Anyway,
shirts,
you like these slogans,
his slogan is that only one word for like discipline equals freedom.
I Dunno.
I think it's going to get factually is what it could be used,
but I don't know that it necessarily,
I'm not waving it around and been up and down.
Yeah.
Although if you ask me a question on Twitter,
like guy asked me the other day,
how can I wake up early?
How can I work out everyday and how can I eat the right foods?
Yeah.
I'm just going to tell you discipline.
Your right.
Right.
There you go.
This is so easy.
Yeah.
Well all the point there is that there's some shirts there.
Cool.
I think they're cool,
but if you think they're cool,
you want to support podcasts,
you get assured a Hoodie,
like some good stuff there.
Then add even some more stuff.
Um,
and look at them.
If you,
if you'd like some stuff,
get some of that support the podcast.
So for yourself to get a new shirt.
It's kind of cool when you order something,
you know the day it comes in,
you know,
even this regular Amazon stuff,
but the little microphone adapter for my other stuff.
It comes into your other stuff.
I do stuff.
This is kind of messed up and then do stuff just doing this
anyway.
So yeah.
Well,
you know,
shirts come in,
you can wear on,
you got a new shirt.
Discipline equals freedom.
Chocolates hits is good backwards.
So when you look in the mirror,
it's telling you good.
Like,
you know that whole thing.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Whatever else.
The coffee mugs,
I'm,
I'm working with this Guy Chris.
He's really helping you narrowed down a better travel travel mug.
Yeah,
the travel.
It's going to be good.
Real good.
That's good.
Yeah.
Oh,
there's stuff on there.
Look at it and nothing.
I'm not saying buy it.
I'm seeing go there.
If you like something to get something,
a interview,
it's a good way to support the podcast.
Yes.
And actually,
so maybe someone will ask you about what that means and you say,
oh,
it's,
I listened to a podcast.
Yup.
Which happens a lot according to my experience and the experience of others that
email me.
They meet,
they spread the word.
People will be like,
what does that mean?
Who's that guy on your shirt?
And if you're like,
and here's a,
here's a funny one that you wouldn't really think of.
So let's say I'm wearing the Jocko.
Good shirt has your face on it,
right?
I'm at my friend's house,
Barbecue,
whatever.
And we're like,
hey,
let's all take a picture and you have the thing and it's,
you know the square that finds the faces.
It's finding your face on my shirt.
And they're like,
oh wait.
They're like,
oh,
it's finding you're the face on your shirt echo.
And then later on they're like,
who's that on your shirt?
Boom.
Spread that work.
You know,
it's like one of those kinds of things.
I like the idea of spreading the word because it's cool is uh,
you know,
we get all,
I get a lot of messages,
people saying,
Hey,
thanks.
Yeah,
I lost 40 pounds.
Hey,
thanks.
I'm back in school.
Hey,
thanks.
I got a promotion.
I'm not doing any of that.
You guys are doing it,
but you are somehow influenced on the fact that you're getting your,
you're getting your discipline together,
you're working hard and you're getting,
your life is getting better.
So when you spread the word,
you're helping somebody else too,
which is cool.
Yep.
100%
oh,
but yeah,
those are the ways you know,
other ways.
There's a psychological warfare in here.
This is never used one,
so no more.
Oh wait,
no.
Every day.
Those are two different ones,
right?
No more in everyday.
Yes,
I believe so.
Yeah.
I listened to the everyday one because you know how like when you're like,
Hey,
I'm gonna,
I'm,
I'm new.
I turned over a new leaf,
whatever the expression is,
I did my new year's resolution.
And you go hard.
Typically.
Typically you go hard and you're like,
oh,
carbs who?
God,
you know,
you don't cut a little bit.
They're gone,
right?
Yeah.
After lake a little while,
usually like four or five days,
you're going to like,
ah,
maybe not gone,
you know.
So you listened to every day write every day.
It really is,
not only does it like make you like fired up to keep going,
but it puts it in perspective.
You know,
it's like you got know this is a Cliche,
but Michael Jordan or something like that.
Someone who's doing someone who's successful,
you know,
he didn't go back to old him five days later and that sounds real obvious and
yet we heard that'd be,
but that's what,
why that's effective.
So psychological were free.
If you don't know it is an album.
Spoken word album is available on iTunes
of like little,
for lack of a better term,
trickle warfare.
Yeah,
like verbal.
You can listen to it.
It tells you to get after it under certain circumstances.
Yes.
There's actually specifically made to deal with common everyday weaknesses that
we all,
yes,
you can just press play track seven track for w o everyone that's asked for an
alarm clock to wake up and just get this album.
Set it as your alarm tone.
I'm waking you up in the morning.
Yup.
Tell your wife,
tell your significant others.
Otherwise they're going to think there's a strange man in the room talking to
them and they're gonna freak out,
pull out their firearm.
Bad things could happen.
But limited psychological warfare.
It's all that tense.
Yeah.
Psycholo
I should think I should put on it like Amazon music too.
That's a good show.
Yeah.
But yeah,
currently iTunes search psychological warfare is on Google play to Jocko
Willink.
Oh,
I dunno.
I Dunno if the podcast is or no,
I know the podcast is the distribution channels you need to expand for sure.
Expand getting the game.
Yeah,
but that's a good one.
And incidentally supports the podcast.
That's true.
Very true.
Which is appreciated.
All right,
so also you can get Jocko white tea that supports the podcast and it supports
you and it's in stock.
We've got a bunch of it and it will do things to you.
If you want to crush the soles of your enemies drinks and Jocko white tea,
it'll be a little bit easier to do that.
You'll,
it'll,
it'll taste better.
So that's that.
We had to get after it.
Mugs,
they're out of stock as I wanted to.
Joe Rogan,
he took a picture of it.
They're gone,
they're gone.
So I got more being ordered.
They're being made logistical nightmare,
all that.
Sorry,
keep checking.
They'll be back in stock.
They say get after it
while you're there on Amazon,
you can also get a book called extreme ownership written by me and my brother
Leif Babin.
It's about leadership and it's about combat,
so if you like the podcast,
you're dig that book.
You know,
I also have another book that's going to be coming out in May.
It's not available for preorder yet,
but it will be,
and I will announce it when it comes out.
I think everyone's going to be pretty psyched on it because I am.
And also the extreme ownership muster.
May 4th and fifth at the Marriott Marquis in New York City.
This is it.
This is the gathering.
It's about leadership.
It's about strategy,
it's about tactics.
It's about getting after Google it,
you'll find it.
We'll see you there and
until we see you there,
if you want to see us well we can actually buy found all up in the interwebs.
We are on Twitter,
we are on Instagram and you gone also could find us on Dash Facebook,
[inaudible]
cruising,
which you,
my Frenchy Echo is at Echo Charles and I am at jockowillink.
Thanks for the support and you know we talk a little bit about these Amazon
clicks and the store purchases and they're getting the t and the mugs and the
teachers and all that stuff.
Just so you know that support is actually literally what fuels the podcast.
That's what the podcast runs off of.
So thanks for all that.
Truly,
we appreciate it.
Thanks to the military,
the military personnel that are out there smashing our enemies
and thanks to law enforcement and firefighters for protecting us here at home.
And the rest of you that are out there listening,
that are working through your lives,
that are building and creating and grinding and finding faults,
finding faults,
not in others,
but in yourselves.
And thank you for crushing those faults by getting out there with discipline
and getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.